[musique]
Albert Dupontel, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
succintement, c'est forcément réducteur.
Ben [grognement] voilà, acteur
réalisateur ou réalisateur acteur euh à
la fois sur le retour au niveau état
civil et puis de retour chez vous
puisque je suis déjà venu il y a un
petit moment de 3 ans je crois. Voilà,
on vous reçoit parce qu'on a été voir
votre dernier film second tour. On a
plein de choses à échanger. On va faire
le point depuis les 3 ans où on s'est
pas vu. [grognement]
Quel regard vous portez sur la vie
politique française, la vie politique
internationale ? Comment ça se passe
votre perception des choses ?
Qui qui suis-je pour avoir pour répondre
à votre question ? pas grand-chose. Donc
il faut mesurer bien ce que je vais dire
mais non je suis perplexe d'un peu
désorienté dans un vrai désarrois une
vraie peur même par rapport à ce qui se
passe et puis j'ai l'impression quand
même qu'ils sont très largement hors sol
c'est qu'il il s'occupent de choses qui
m'intéressent pas forcément et je pense
que je suis pas le seul quoi. On est le
4 septembre il fait 30°gr c'est un
problème qui est majeur quoi et c'est
pas vraiment encore le problème c'est
toujours pas majeur pour ces gens-là qui
s'occupent de de PIB d'indice de
croissance d'économie et on a vu ça
pendant le Covid d'ailleurs. Le Covid
pour eux c'était une crise économique
c'était pas une crise sanitaire. Donc le
le citoyen que je suis est un peu est un
peu perplexe. Voilà, si je peux employer
des mots polis.
Quand on est perplexe face à la vie
politique, on fait des films, on fait
quoi ?
Bah moi, je fais des films, je suis
perplexe globalement devant l'existence.
Voilà. Qu'est-ce que je fais là ? Où je
vais, d'où je viens et cetera. En même
temps, le doute c'est c'est la grandeur
d'un individu. C'est pour ça que moi je
je réfute les institutions, je réfute
les religieux, je réfute tout ça. Voilà,
je je veux douter même si parfois ça
mène dans des abîmes de perplexité. Donc
le le mon cursus, voilà, j'ai j'étais
inséré dans la vie comment dire sociale,
professionnelle et puis le doute
métaphysique était tellement fort que je
ne trouvais un refuge psychique dans les
salles de Sino quoi. Donc effectivement,
je comprends mieux l'imaginaire que la
réalité. Donc je commmente la réalité
via des films. C'est une façon
relativement élégante de s'exprimer. Je
vous saoule pas hein, je viens une fois
tous les 3 ans avec mon petit film et
voilà, c'est un commentaire, c'est un
commentaire que je fais. Donc la
politique m'intéresse pas. C'est c'est
un décorum que j'ai fait par rapport à
l'autre histoire. Il y a des sujets qui
m'intéressent plus fort dans dans dans
second tour sans dévoiler le film mais
voilà la différence entre avoir été
éduqué, avoir été aimé, c'est très
différent, c'est très important. Après,
il y a un décorum politique parce que
forcément oui, j'avais déjà dit la
dernière fois donc mais c'est vrai que
c'est parti d'un documentaire sur Robert
Kennedy que je recommande encore une
fois. Absolument passionnant. Il il y a
ce discours qu'il a fait, on peut le
trouver sur Netflix, je crois, qu'il a
fait à la police ou tout d'un coup, il
apprend en direct au dans un ghetto
black en pleine campagne électorale en
ce qui concerne la sienne. Il leur
apprend la mort de Martin Luther King.
Je crois qu'il y a pas pire nouvelle
qu'on puisse annoncer à ces gens-là dans
ce contexte- làà il y a 20 30000
personnes. Donc il leur annonce, il y a
il y a un cri d'effroi dans la foule et
d'horreur et de tristesse et
d'indignation et cetera et tout. Puis
après il leur parle avec forcément un
discours préparé puisque lui aussi vient
de l'apprendre quelques minutes avant.
Il y a une parole sincère, convaincante,
forte. 10 minutes après, il est applaudi
par la foule comme extraordinaire des
larmes il passe à l'applaudissement et
puis la seule ville des États-Unis où il
y a pas eu des meux de ce soit-là, c'est
Indianapolis qui prouve que quand une
parole politique est sincère,
convaincante, intelligente, elle a un
vrai poids. Voilà. Alors partant de de
cette chose réaliste, historique et
mouvante, on a on a brodé une fable
totalement improbable mais voilà, c'est
le principe du cinéma, c'est d'être
assez sagrenue avec la réalité. Donc de
ce côté-là, on s'en sait pas privé,
quoi.
C'est c'est dangereux quand on a en
politique une une parole sincère, forte.
Bah, on a vu comment ça s'est terminé
pour Kennedy. Ouais, il il a il a il a
été il a été assassiné quoi. Un mec
aussi qui est avancé. Alors lui, il a
rusé, c'est dans notre histoire de
France d'ailleurs. C'est un grand
personnage, c'est de Gaulle qui qui a
rusé. Je vous ai compris, ça veut tout
dire. Donc, il a été mis en place par
des gens mais qui qu'il avait la ferme
intention de trahir et je crois qu'il y
a eu six ou sep tentatives d'assassinat
dans son Septena. Donc ça donnait la
grandeur au personnage. Il a sa démarche
oui donc c'est dangereux. Donc c'est
dangereux. Ouais, effectivement. Ouais.
Fait une pub pour Citroën.
La voiture de l'attentat du petit
clamar. Ouais. Elle était blindée je
crois. Sa voiture
non ? Elle roulait sur trois roues.
Ah oui oui mais le gars avait réussi à
s'en sortir.
Quand on on fait second tour, quelle
idée on a derrière la tête ? Qu'est-ce
qu'on a envie de faire passer aux gens ?
L'idée principale c'est
on spoile pas.
Non non je spoile pas mais
je fais très sérieusement quelque chose
dans lequel on se prend pas au sérieux.
C'est très important. Moi ce que je veux
c'est distraire les gens. Après je suis
imbibé de névrose, d'angoisse que
j'exorcise forcément dans mon travail.
Et donc tout d'un coup ce confinement,
l'attitude des dirigeants globalement
leur attitude par rapport à ce qu'on a
nous des des petits citoyens, des
petites gens, je m'inclus dans le tas,
elle est forcément troublante. Elle est
elle est elle nous mon dans une vraie
perplexité, dans un vrai désarrois. Donc
comment la raconter ? Bah moi ce que je
veux, c'est distraire les gens au
départ. Le grand cinéaste, le grand
classique pour moi au cinéma, c'est
Chaplin. Chaplin raconte des histoires
émouvantes, fortes, tragique et toujours
il nous distrait. Un grand film
politique de Chaplin c'est l'étant
moderne. Et comment mieux résumer le
l'industrialisation du 20e siècle par
rapport à ça ? Alors, il y a il y a un
cin que que je vénère aussi, c'est Ken
Lach. Al Kench il dit qu'il fait des
films pour provoquer l'indignation des
gens. Moi, je considère que
l'indignation, elle est déjà là et en
bon petit bourgeois, je cherche à
distraire les gens avec cette
indignation. Vous comprenez la la
nuance, elle est importante. Donc voilà,
donc je je vois ce documentaire, je suis
dans un contexte particulier et j'essaie
j'ébouche une histoire qui est soit une
femme, soit un roman de gar, c'est
selon. Mais voilà, c'est ça que je suis
en train de chercher à raconter. Et si
les gens pendant 1 heure et demi passent
un bon moment, je suis au somum de mon
ambition. J'en ai pas d'autres. Donc
message tout ça, c'est un peu sérieux.
Bien sûr qu'il y en a. Bien sûr parce
qu'on aborde des thèmes qui concernent
les gens. Le le désarrois que je
partage, enfin que j'ai en moi, il est
partagé, on voit bien, par plein de
gens. Mais je me risque pas un quelcon
discours sérieux. La la la le le film
passe à travers un personnage Nicolas
Marié pour ne pas le nommer, qui s'en
sort très bien avec un personnage
improbable et qui amuse les gens. Et
puis il y a la grande Cécile de France
qui régule le tout et cetera et cetera.
Donc nous voilà, on passe par nos codes,
notre façon de fonctionner, quelle la
quel divertissement, quelle est la
fiction et et on résume finalement, je
pense un déservoir général. Voilà.
Comment on fait autrement que comment
quand on est Albert Du Pontel ? Comment
on fait pour exorciser ces démos en
dehors de faire des films déjà ? Comment
on fait pour les identifier ? Comment on
fait pour faire le périmètre ?
Bah c'est un lâcher-prise intérieur mais
qui existe depuis depuis longtemps. Moi
quand j'étais en médecine effectivement
l'effet mérité de mon existence était
vraiment aveuglante parce que je l'avais
chez
alors je disais la vie même quand ça se
passe bien objectivement ça a mal se
terminé.
[rires]
Alors alors à partir de là forcément
voilà il y a un vrai désenvoi et moi je
n'arrive plus à affronter en quelque
sorte j'arrive plus à affronter Newton
donc je me réfugie chez Rimbou pour
prendre des métaphores s'il y en a parmi
vos vos spectateurs qui qu'on dépassé le
BBS et donc voilà et je me réfugiais
avec ces gens-là enfin avec surtout avec
Rabot et j'essaie de de raconter des
émotions intérieures qui est une vraie
j'ai pas de solution moi par rapport à
mon désarrois simplement ça fait du bien
de les exorciser moi ça me fait du bien
de faire des films c'est la seule chose
que je peux dire en plus des fois je
gagne un peu de sous donc ça me permet
de vivre Donc c'est c'est pas mal comme
truc mais j'ai pas de réponse. Voilà et
je je n'aurais Il y a une phrase de
Cocto qui est assez marrante. On lui
disait "Qu'est-ce que vous direz à Dieu
quand vous le rencontrerez ?" Il il
avait dit "Remboursez-moi, j'ai rien
compris." Voilà, [rires]
ça beaucoup fait rire Belmondo un soir
où j'ai raconté ça et et voilà. Bah oui,
effectivement, il y a rien à comprendre.
Alors après cette perplexité, bah il y
en a qui qui la subissent, il y en a qui
se posent pas de questions. D'ailleurs,
tous les les dominants font tout pour
qu'on se pose pas de questions. Les
marchands nous disent "Consommer, tout
ça n'est pas très grave. consommer,
manger, buvez, dormez, mourz. Les
politiques disent "Suivez-moi, vous voir
la vie va être meilleure." Et puis les
religieux disent "J'ai un manuel."
Voilà, c'est Manuel il sort le nouveau
testament. Voilà ce qu'il faut faire.
Voilà d'où on vient, voilà ce qu'il faut
faire. Voilà ce qui va se passer après.
Bon, tout ça me paraît un peu si
T'obéis pas, tu vas dans les enfers
et puis voilà, c'est c'est on n'est pas
voilà, si on a 5 ans, on peut y croire,
après c'est un peu plus compliqué. Ce
qui est dommage avec la religion, c'est
qu'on c'est qu'on nous la colle assez
tôt. Moi, j'ai été baptisé un an, j'ai
aucune force pour protester. Après, ils
m'ont foutu au catéchisme et cetera et
puis ils m'ont inculqué la morale. La
morale. Ce truc qui a été inventé par
les par les gens qui sentent coupables.
C'est une phrase de camu. Et après toute
notre vie, il faut se débrouiller avec
cette [__] de morale alors qu'on se
rend compte que la vie n'a aucune
morale. Je l'ai pu le voir, des enfants
de 3 ans mourir d'un cancer et cetera et
cetera. Donc la vie, elle a pas de
moral. Donc ça c'est l'homme s'invente
des règles devant la perplexité de vivre
et alors qu'il est lui-même un miracle
biologique. Voyez, je suis en train de
vous parler là, j'actionne 300000
mécanisme physiologique extrêmement
sophistiqué et puis je suis animé de tas
d'émotions intérieures. Mais quand on va
à l'école, pour revenir sur un de mes
sujets de prédilection, on vous on vous
apprend vite à participer au monde
extérieur, mais on vous apprend pas à
participer à votre monde intérieur.
Pourquoi je suis en colère ? Pourquoi je
suis frustré ? Pourquoi je suis amoureux
? Pourquoi je suis triste ? Pourquoi ça
c'est des vraies questions qu'on doit se
poser. Alors après des des ruptures
sociales comme ça été mon cas, bah oui
fait qu' tout d'un coup on s'interroge
sur qui on est, où on va et on se
documente et puis on finit par faire des
films parce que c'est parce que je suis
un auteur impuissant [rires]
avec le cinéma. Bah j'ai la lumière,
j'ai la musique, j'ai des grands acteurs
comme c'est Nicolas et d'autres. Voilà,
je je triche. C'est un je suis un auteur
frustré, incapable, impuissant. Alors je
triche avec le syche. Voilà.
Quand on fait une préparation de ce type
de film, on fait quoi ? On regarde la
télé, on regarde des discours
politiques.
J'ai pas de télé, j'ai j'ai pas mal
bibronné à votre à votre émission.
[rires]
Quel est votre préféré ?
Euh la lecture, beaucoup de
documentaires, beaucoup d'essais,
beaucoup de Alors, ça va de Jung à à une
relecture des essais de montagne, ça va
de de de gens qui sont passés par chez
vous qui m'ont filé la documentation. Il
y a un mec comme Galant, Jean Covici qui
m'a la BD sa BD là qui fait un gros
succès est vraiment très intéressante.
D'autres encore Louratourou
la rou très très intéressant parce que
ces gens-là vulgarisent quelque chose
qui est compliqué des fois à comprendre
et puis il y en a d'autres aussi Tod il
était plutôt marrant il y a un autre mec
connaî ça qui qui une verve un peu au
gardienne [rires] et qui parle de
l'Arabie Saoudite parce du coup j'ai
acheté leur bouquin et cetera tout ça
c'est un petit un petit un petit brain
trust et puis mais au départ il y a une
indignation citoyenne voilà mais qui est
basique hein qui qui est un peu chez
tout le monde et le fait de faire des
films encore une fois ça fait du bien.
Donc c'est c'est pas c'est pas méchant.
Quel Quel est le dernier discours ou
quelle est le la dernière allocution
politique que vous ayez entendu ? C'est
le discours de Macron 14 juillet. Il
Non non non non, moi j'ai pas de télé
déjà donc c'est compliqué de les
entendre mais je suis tombé un peu par
hasard sur un truc qui m'a rendu triste
qui éta assez rigolo, c'est justement le
représentant de notre culture parce que
moi quand je dis je suis français,
j'évoque pas la patrie, j'évoque pas la
nation, j'évoque la culture. Là, on est
issu, vous et moi d'une grande culture
qui est une culture française, une des
plus belles cultures au monde qui a
généré des grands scientifiques, des
pasteurs, des curies, des des grands
peintes, des impressionnistes, des
grands écrivains avec une vraie
conscience politique comme Hugo et
cetera et cetera. Donc voilà, quand on
est le représentant de cette culture, on
doit tenir compte. Voilà, culture encore
une fois qui qui prône la la liberté de
parole, qui prône la lacité, qui prône
le droit de l'homme, qui prône l'égalité
homme-femme. Et je dis pas que c'est que
c'est en pratique tous les jours dans ce
pays. C'est c'est pas un paragon de
vertu la France. Mais malgré tout, c'est
c'est ces idées là, ces ces évalors là
et alors [rires] j'aime pas le foot
comme vous le savez mais je suis quand
même tombé sur des extraits de la la
finale d'une coupe du monde qui se passe
dans un pays totalement improbable et
notre représentant en train de s'agiter
comme un adaient
peut-être mettre la babale dans les
filets. Bon voilà dans une tribune
climatisée dans un pays où il fait 50°gr
fait par des Banginglades dont la moitié
sont sont repartis estropiers ou morts
dans leur pays entouré de gens pour qui
le mot démocratie est quand même très
largement abstrait.
[rires]
dans des pays où on met les homosexuels
en prison où les femmes ont appellent le
droit de conduire et puis à la fin il
est allé faire un gros câlin à un joueur
dont le salaire moyen doit être le PIB
du Yémen parce qu'il avait pas mis la
babal dans les filet bon [rires]
entre rire et tristesse, voilà, je sais
pas trop me situer mais je me
reconnaissais pas ma question j'ai dit
mais je suis qui moi voilà la question
je me suis posé c'est mais je suis qui
moi je suis français vraiment je suis
pas français à ce moment-là je suis
perdu je suis avec des mecs puis
peut-être qu' un gars du gouvernement
nous expliquerait qu'ils ont fourgué des
rafales au Qatar Quoi ? [rires]
Dommage qu'ils aient pas fourgué des
vaccins ou des plans pour faire des
hôpitaux ou amener l'université
française et ses valeurs. Donc
l'Occident est malade de l'argent depuis
la Renaissance. Ça c'est vraiment
accentué depuis 30 ans et puis euh avec
la fameuse mondialisation et puis nos
représentants bah ils sont pas à la
hauteur de ce qui se passe parce
qu'aujourd'hui encore une fois on est le
4 septembre, il fait 30°gr quoi donc ça
me paraît le plus urgent c'est ça quoi
me semble-t-il. Voilà, c'est que ça ça
change rien sur le partage des richesses
et l'écoute et cetera. Ça change rien.
Tout est dans le même packaging.
Forcément que ce qui se passe doit nous
per nous pousser à nous rapprocher, à
communiquer, à partager. C'est obligé.
Alors à quoi bon perdre du temps avec
ces conneries de babal ? Voilà. Voilà ma
dernière indignation citoyenne.
Est-ce que vous est-ce que vous est-ce
que tu arriverais à me décrire euh cette
sensation qui t'attrape le bulbe
rachidien qui t'attrape la moinière ou
qui te fait tomber les bras ?
Non non mais ça me fait marrer. Ça me
fait marrer.
Est-ce que c'est ça te fait marrer sur
une faille spatiotemporelle relativement
triste ? Bah oui, c'est comme dans un
film quand un mec se casse la gueule, on
se marre mais on aimerait pas tu à la
place du gars qui tombe. Alors si c'est
en gros plan, ça fait mal parce qu'on
craque mais si c'est en plan large,
c'est principe de Chapelin, on rigole
parce que c'est de loin, c'est un peu
abstrait. Donc là, c'est de loin, c'est
un peu abstrait, ça me fait marrer. Je
suis pas dans la tribune à côté. Enfin,
j' aurais jamais été. De toute façon, il
aurait fallu 85 tonnes en plus de
kérosène pour y aller en avion. Donc
c'est [rires] vraiment tout faux sur la
présentation de notre culture. Voilà.
Non non, ça me fait rire. Voilà, ça me
fait rire. Ça ça me désole. C'est un
rire. Ouais, c'est un rire d'adolescent
qui qui se veut sarcastique puis qui est
un peu désolé. L'adulte quand même dit
c'est un peu con quand même quoi. Et
puis je crois qu'ils se rendent pas
compte, ils se rendent pas compte. Ils
sont dans une image de même. Ils sont
assez euphoriques he ces gens. Ils sont
assez euphoriques. Le pouvoir doit
rendre euphorique. Ils sont tous
euphoriques. Il y a que nous qui ne
sommes pas. On est en dessous nous. On
n'est pas on a envie de dire "Et les
gars, c'est peut-être pas ça ce qu'il
faut faire quoi." Je sais pas.
Et et si c'est pas ça ce qu'il faut
faire, pourquoi ils écoutent pas ?
Pourquoi ils sont
Bah, ils écoutent pas parce qu' ils ont
été formés pour faire autre chose. Moi
je parle de Macron. Macron je jeen veux
pas. Même si j'en voulais, je crois
qu'il s'en foutrai très largement.
[rires]
Mais c'est quelqu'un qui a été formé
pour faire ce qu'il fait. Voilà, c'est
un c'est un banquier Macron. La
technocratie dont il est issu. Je crois
qu'il a fait l'ENAT finalement
[grognement] a débouché sur une carrière
de banquier et aujourd'hui c'est c'est
la finance qui domine le monde. C'est le
marchand c'était cette chose.
D'ailleurs, je l'évoque je me permets de
l'évoquer dans dans second tour. Adame
Smith dit que ce qu'il a fait c'est
qu'il a dans le capital dans dans la
richesse des nations pardon dans la
richesse des nations, ce qu'il a ce
qu'il a voulu faire c'était rétablir la
libre circulation de l'argent qui était
un domaine préservé chez les
aristocrates et cetera. tout ça c'est
même il a jamais imaginé la spéculation
et puis l'argent est devenu une valeur
en tant que telle l'argent au départ
c'est juste une façon de communiquer
entre des gens qui qui parlent pas le
même langage. Ils veulent faire du
commerce parce que le libre marché c'est
intéressant quand c'est régulé, quand
c'est raisonnable. C'est intéressant.
Ça finance les entreprises.
Oui, mais il y a des trucs intéressants
dans dans dans les comis de marché à
condition qu'elles soit raisonnable.
Alors, c'est intéressant, je suis tombé
encore une fois sur internet parce que
c'est un peu le le le seul média que je
fréquente de temps en temps sur un un
short sur YouTube sur de Gaul qui
parlent du capitalisme. C'est très
intéressant. Voilà, on a quelqu'un qui
est supposé de droite et en fait qui dit
que le capital le capitalisme c'est
vraiment pas une solution et c'est que
ça débouche sur l'analéation mentale des
travailleurs. Il a complètement raison
ce ce vieux monsieur. Voilà.
Donc donc voilà, donc je je sais plus
quel é votre question, mais je je je ris
de tout ça et puis j'essaie après de
m'exprimer sans être un militant ni quoi
que ce soit. Le le militant à la
politique, il est c'est un peu comme
l'intégriste dans la religion. C'est
quand même quelqu'un qui a une lecture
très très très petite du discours. Et et
donc je fais des films, voilà, je je
commente à ma façon. C'est bien de faire
des films, c'est c'est du travail. On
rencontre des gens, on travaille la
lumière, les acteurs, tout c'est c'est
du boulot. Même faire un mauvais film,
je je vous mets à l'aise. Même faire un
mauvais film, c'est du travail. Il y a
quand on on prépare un film sur la
politique euh parce que sans dévoiler le
le l'intégrité de du film, quand on
prépare un film comme ça qu'on s'appelle
Albert Dontel, euh est-ce que est-ce que
vous pensez que les politiques vous
survent ?
Ils s'en foutent complètement
franchement. Non, ils s'en foutent. Ils
s'en foutent de qui je suis. Ils s'en
foutent. C'est là, on dit qu'ils sont un
peu hors sol d'ailleurs. Il y a pas
longtemps, je j'étais en Normandie. Je
je tombe de façon très émouvante sur une
dame. Je pensais plus qu'elle était de
ce monde. C'était ma nounou. En fait,
quand j'étais mom, j'ai eu une enfance
un petit peu un petit peu agitée. Donc
j'étais en Normandie. Voilà. Et puis je
tombe sur cette dame en pleine on me dit
juste avant qu'elle est dans dans la
salle et tout et je peux pas m'empêcher
pendant le débat de dire il y a une dame
je pas eu depuis 50 ans, elle se lève et
tout. Bref, je vous passe les détails de
l'émotion mais l'émotion passée d'abord
c dame est devenue aveugle et toute sa
ville s'est occupé des gens, des enfants
et des gens. C'est quelqu'un
profondément d'altruiste. Il y a plein
de gens comme ça qui s'occupent
d'association qui sont qui ont le cœur
sur la main qui sont sincères, c'est les
petites gens et on dit souvent que les
braves gens quand il y a des
difficultés, ils deviennent des gens
braves. Voilà. bah c'est quelqu'un qui
est brave, qui est devenu aveugle et ben
elle a décliné son talent et et et son
altruisme aux gamins qui sont aveugles.
Elle essaie de les faire passer de de
l'école c'est parce qu'elle connaît bien
le dossier forcément elle essaie de les
instruire, de les faire passer les
écoles avec toutes les techniques de
bras et cetera et tout et après
l'émotion elle me dit voilà le le la
région Normandie a coupé les subventions
pour 2024, j'ai plus de sous quoi. Alors
bon moi sûr de ma célébrité [rires]
qui fait j'attends je vais te filer un
coup de main. Donc je en de en de en de
deux de deux SMS je trouve le nom du
président de région. Donc vous allez me
rappeler, je me rappelle plus qui c'est.
Voilà. Bref, je lui envoie un petit SMS
très poli l'invitant à une projection
dans des films parce qu'on a fait 10
ville en Normandie quand même. Très
bien. D'ailleurs, c'est c'est ça une
région très chouette et et [grognement]
et disant voilà, j'aimerais vous parler
d'un petit dossier Salot. Non, mon idée
c'était de faire un petit coup
médiatique ensemble. Voilà, en citoyen
politique pour trouver des sous pour le
montant c'est 80000 €. Donc je parlais
de footballeur, je pense que c'est la
demi-journée de travail d'un footballeur
professionnel aujourd'hui. Donc pour
80000 € c'est vraiment pas grand-chose.
Bah il m'a jamais répondu si vous
voulez. Donc bah voilà, quand même
merde, je j'ai peut-être plus de
spectateurs qu'il y en a des lecteurs,
ça serait bien quand même qu'on puisse
communiquer.
Donc voilà, j'étais un petit peu j'étais
un petit peu perplexe. Et alors voilà,
ça c'est une petite indignation qui
peut-être se répercutera dans dans un
prochain film quoi.
Quand quand quand l'indignation vient
comme ça, est-ce que c'est le rôle des
cinéastes et des les saletban du de la
culture de dire ha ? Bien sûr. Enfin, oh
là, on changera jamais rien. Chapine n'a
fait le dictateur. Ça peut empêcher la
seconde guerre mondiale. Mais c'est un
commentaire. Même si le commentaire est
triste et que il choque les gens et
cetera, le cinéaste ou ou le peintre ou
l'écrivain, c'est un messager. Faut pas
tuer le messager, il arrive avec une
mauvaise nouvelle, une mauvaise
nouvelle. Voilà, moi je commmente un
monde qui existe. J'ai pas inventé moi
le réchauffement climatique, l'écologie,
les politiques, hors sol, kennedé. J'ai
pas inventé ça. Donc j'arrive dans un
monde, vous et moi on appartient à une
espèce qui a tué 100 millions de ses
semblables au 20e siècle. Comment
voulez-vous qu'on nit pas en nous un
sentiment de culpabilité du survivant et
puis aussi peur du barbare qu'on peut
être. Vous comprenez ? Il y a l'espèce
humaine, c'est Mozart, c'est BOV, c'est
Hugo puis c'est aussi Hitler et la choix
et on a tout ça en nous quand même.
Des fois je me fais peur.
Donc faire des films, c'est un c'est un
c'est un curseur qui permet de réguler
ses humeurs parce que vous c'est du
travail. travail, c'est de l'argent,
c'est du temps. Donc déjà on cherche à
être clair. Un artiste, c'est quelqu'un
qui est qui est dévoré par ses émotions.
N'ayons pas peur des mots, même submergé
et qui cherche à les mettre en ordre
pour les exprimer, pour que ça soit
clair, pour que les gens les partagent
parce que je me rends compte qu'elles
sont partagées ces émotions, pas par
tout le monde mais par beaucoup de gens.
Donc mettre de l'ordre dans ces
émotions, c'est un vrai travail. Vous me
demandez comment on fait, bah on se met
au travail. Voilà, je je sur un prochain
projet, je prends des notes puis à un
moment donné c'est c'est c'est anxiogène
ce climat. Faut écrire puis on fait lire
et puis ça va pas puis on recommence
second tour on a fait quatre it pendant
le film on montrait le film au genson
discrètement toujours avec des des
projections pendant le montage. Et puis
des fois les gens excusez-moi mais
[rires]
dans les petits commentaires, j'ai j'ai
juste rien compris.
Alors on refait on fait des ryth et tout
on refait des trucs et tout. Voilà
s'appelle çaappelle chercher à être
clair. Voilà parce que les films que les
gens aiment pas le film c'est le risque
qu'on prend. C'est leurs droits. C'est
leur goût. Ça c'est vraiment hautement
respectable. Mais que on soit lent ou
confus c'est une faute professionnelle.
Donc au moins, on essaie même si on est
indigeste d'être clair. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous connaissez Tom Clany ?
Bien sûr, bien sûr. Ouais, c'est un
grand auteur de de roman d'espionnage
américain. Ouais, j'ai vu il y a pas
longtemps la poursuite d'OT rouge avec
mon gamin qui adore ça. À 9 ans, il trou
ça super.
De quoi ? La poursuite d'octobre.
Oui, voilà. Le film le film il a pas
encore lu mais c'est un bon lecteur. Il
le lira tôt ou tard. Ouais.
Quel regard vous portez sur la
géopolitique qui nous entoure en ce
moment 3 ans après ? Bah je vous dis,
ils sont effectivement c'est bien de
parler de 3 ans après parce que le le
Covid n'a servit à rien les tant qu'on
n' pas touché le fond, il y aura pas de
réaction. Le problème si vous voulez
c'est que le problème il est mondial et
que c'est un c'est une bagarre contre
nous-même qu'on est en train de de
faire. C'est pas les Allemands euh
quelque part c'était pratique l'ennemi
une croix gamé des casques. Mais là
c'est notre mode de vie, c'est notre
consum notre consommation frénétique,
c'est nos habitudes dans cette pièce. Il
y a du matériel a il y a 100 ans il aura
fallu 200 personnes pour faire ce que
vous êtes en train de faire. Donc on est
la planète, elle peut pas livrer ça tout
le temps. Elle est il parle toujours de
l'indice de croissance mais l'indice de
croissance plus il grimme plus la
planète fond. On est dans un monde fini.
Alors la connaissance, la culture elle
est infinie. L'imagination elle est
infinie. Ça au moins, on peut s'appuyer
là-dessus.
La connerie aussi elle est infinie.
Bah oui, c'est c'est la phrase
d'Instein. Je crois que l'univers est
infini ainsi que la bêtise humaine.
Encore que pour l'univers, je suis pas
sûr. [rires]
Il beaucoup [grognement] d'humour ce
personnage. Je partage avec lui le
prénom. Voilà. Voyez,
si euh nos politiques euh que ce soit
française, européenne ou occidental se
dirige vers une mauvaise voie euh on
fait quoi ?
Bah,
on fait quoi pour les alerter ? On fait
des films
à ti perso bah je oui, je fais des films
mais encore une fois, ce ne sont que des
films. En plus, la culture française
c'est sport les films hein.
Non non non mais c'est c'est chacun
s'exprime comme il peut. C'est je crois
pas que le droit de vote des proches
disaient que si si le vote servait à
quelque chose, ça serait interdit. Donc
voilà, moi j'ai suis toujours abstenu de
voter parce que je me suis jamais
retrouvé dans cette façon de faire de la
politique. C'est la politique
politicienne. Je ne la comprends pas. En
France, l'écologie est de gauche. Je ne
vois pas pourquoi l'écologie est de
gauche. C'est un problème d'union
nationale. Le gros débat dans les
écologistes là, ça a été de faire venir
un rappeur qui avait tenu des propos
antisémites. Qu'est-ce qu'on en a à
[__] ? qui nous explique comment
replanter des forêts, qui nous explique
comment mettre les avions de ligne
domestique en France au sol sans [__]
les gens au chômage. C'est ça qu'on
attend de c'est un truc pragmatique
parce que des solutions il y en a. Il y
a des mecs qui sont passés chez vous. Il
y a un mec Gunter Poly. Voilà Poli donc
d'ailleurs je me suis inspiré de son nom
Bolly don second tour qui donne des
solutions plutôt intéressantes plutôt
marrantes. Ga Girot d'ailleurs les
soutiens et il y a des solutions. Il y a
une société civile qui est vivace qui
est intelligente qui est créative mais
la parole elle est squatée. Ouais. Elle
est squatterée par une une aristocratie
qui est dominante [grognement] et puis
qui tient tout aujourd'hui he qui tient
les médias, qui tient qui tient le
pouvoir. Voilà. Puis il mettent des gens
à eux en place. Pas faut pas se le
cacher. Ça a jamais été aussi ostensible
l'arrivée de Macron pouvoir que que que
les dominants mettaient quelqu'un en
place. Avant c'était plus ou moins caché
même si Chirak Mitang mais forcément on
narrive pas au pouvoir innocemment. Mais
là c'est très ostensible donc c'est un
peu choquant. Voilà. Et alors qu'est-ce
qu'on fait nous ? Bah qu'est-ce qu'on
fait nous ? Il faut éviter de tout
casser parce que finalement ça leur fait
leur jeu.
La violence,
on a toujours tort quand on quand on
même si on a raison dans le fond, on a
tort. Alors des fois elle est inévitable
mais il y a certainement d'autres
solutions. Il faut laisser la parole.
Voilà si on tombait sur des gens
démocrates
sincères, j'ai envie de dire gentil, il
nous donnerait la parole. Le RC c'est
très intéressant. Les propositions du RC
sont très intéressantes. Tout a été
enterré. Supprimer la TVA matière
première. Bien sûr que c'est bien sûr ça
aidé les gens par rapport à la crise de
l'inflation. Il y a tas de gens qui ont
besoin de produits de première nécessité
pour vivre. Donc des idées, il y en a
plein quoi. Mais attends, bah oui, il
les expriment des fois parce qu'ils
entendent la rumeur populaire, elle les
exprime mais dans les actes, ils font
rien. Mais c'est pas neuf, hein. C'est
pas ce gouvernement là en particulier.
Il est particulièrement hors sol
celui-là. Mais mais avant c'était
pareil, faut pas faut pas se raconter de
salade. Alors quand il y a des grandes
tragédies dans l'histoire, la Première
Guerre mondiale, Clémenceau, je vous
recommande les lectures des discours de
Clémenceau, c'est harant et c'est juste
et c'est fort et c'est pas lui, c'est
Anatole France qui a dit on meurt pas
pour la patrie, on meurt pour les
intérêts des multinationales. Il a dit
ça en 1920 quand même. Et donc voilà, il
y a des paroles fortes qui existent.
Mais alors vous voyez Kennedy ce
soir-là, il parle et puis Indianapolis,
il y a pas il y a pas des meutes. Donc
ça prouve bien que les gens sont prêts à
entendre la condition entendre quoi ?
les résultats du foot ou un discours
démagogique à la con. Non, ils peuvent
plus entendre ça. Alors, ils se replient
sur eux et ça donne les communautés, ça
donne les problèmes qu'on a à l'école,
enfin chacun se replie sur soi. C'est le
le grand drame de la modélisation, c'est
le repli identitaire parce que même les
laïques ont besoin de spiritualité. Moi,
je crois, je suis laïque hein, enfin
agnostique mais je crois au mystère
cosmique. Je crois que que que la vie a
un sens. Il est dur à trouver, je vous
le cache pas. Chapline disait l'amour
donne un sens à la vie. Mais qu'on c'est
pas l'amour bénioui, c'est l'amour de la
beauté, c'est l'amour de la nature,
c'est l'amour de la culture. C'est ça.
Ça on peut C'est un foison, on peut en
avoir encore une fois notre culture,
elle est immense. Donc c'est pas quand
le prof dit lisez les misérabes page 40,
page 60 déjà on a pas envie. Dès qu'il
ouvre la bouche le prof on s'emmerde
quoi. Il dirait il y a le feu quitter le
bâtiment. Rien que pour le faire chier,
on quitterait pas le bâtiment. [rires]
C'est normal, c'est notre identité. Il
faut quand même qu'on existe dans ce
dans ce malstrome. Mais après, quand
vous découvrez vraiment ce que ces
gens-là ont dit, bah ouais, c'est des
paroles puissantes, fortes. Alors, il
faut y arriver quoi. Voilà,
il y a une paire de qualité avec le 21e
siècle. Nos nos politiques s'intéressent
uniquement ou nous polarisent, nous
focalisent que sur l'écume des choses
parce qu'il y a peut-être pas de
solution sur les les
Il y en a des solutions. Ça c'est pareil
qu'il y en a pas. Il y en a des
solutions. Il y en a des solutions. Mes
parents ils ont grandi pendant la
guerre, c'était épouvantable.
On en est sorti. Maintenant, le
problème, il est mondial et puis encore
une fois, c'est un mode de vie. Donc
c'est les gens qui parlent qu' pouvoir
ne sont pas ceux qui devraient être en
place. Voilà, c'est la seule critique
que je pourrais faire. Il en faudrait
d'autres
qui
alors c'est marrant parce que peu de
temps en préparant le le le
film là, on était en pleine préparation,
il y a l'interview de Jean Covici, je
crois pas cit chez vous ailleurs et Jean
Covici dit, on lui dit "Mais pourquoi
vous présentez pas ?" Parce qu'il a des
solutions, il en propose lui aussi.
C'était chez il a dit "Fra j'avance
masqué". C'est intéressant, c'est
exactement le sujet du prochain film.
Voilà. J'avance masqué. Quels sont les
lobby ? Quelles sont la puissance
financière qui va soutenir un gars qui
dit il faut mettre les avions au sol,
replanter des forêts, mettre des roues
de pistic là partout. Les lobby vont
dire non être gentil mais et puis il
vont brandir le côté j'emploie 30 40
50000 personnes. Le jour où le politique
dit mettez les chômages, je m'en occupe
parce que je suis assez doué et je sais
où trouver l'argent pour m'occuper de
ces gens dans leur formation à venir.
Alors là ils seront bahà on reprend
quelque part le peuple reprendra le
pouvoir intelligemment pas en coupant
les têtes quand c'est 789 quand même. É
une grosse boucherie, il faut jamais
l'oublier quoi. Chaque année on s le 14
juillet. Bon, c'était une grosse
boucherie pendant plusieurs années.
Ça sentait le faire.
Ouais. Euh, il y a Olivier Duau. Vous
voyez ce que qui c'est Olivier Dusseau ?
Il fait des pompes le matin. Il est très
sportif, il est ministre ou il était
ministre.
Il a fait une déclaration très sensée à
l'Assemblée nationale. Il a dit "Voilà
OK, vous vous proposez un changement de
système mais le je résume trivialement
mais le trou d'air que ça va nous
apporter, est-ce que le trou d'air va
pas être plus sû ? C'est sûr. Non, c'est
sûr. Pour ça, il faut être malin. Non,
mais un moment donné, [grognement] je
mon bonhomme, il dit tout changer, c'est
comme dans une ruche, tout changer sans
rien casser, c'est difficile. Oui, c'est
difficile. C'est pour ça que souvent ça
passe par des tragédies mondiales, des
guerres, des grands progrès sociaux
finalement qu'on a eu au 20e siècle et
la sécurité sociale,
le droit de vote des femmes et tout, il
a fallu une seconde guerre. Si on
pouvait éviter de tuer 50 millions de
personnes pour faire des avancées,
serait plutôt pas mal. Non, il va y
avoir un trou d'air mais faut être
malin. Mais faut déjà envisager le trou
d'air. Aujourd'hui, le problème, c'est
qu'il envisage même pas.
par crainte du trou d'air, il disent non
de toute façon on va pas y aller, on va
se casser la gueule. Attendez les gars,
non, étudier la question quand même et
intéressez-nous la question parce que
vous allez voir qu'il y a des gens
intelligents qui vont on peut y aller
progressivement. Les gens sont prêts à
entendre, les gens sont prêts à agir et
par peur de ce fameux trou aussi par des
intérêts qui sont très heureux de la
situation parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils
vont échapper aussi autoréalisatrice.
Oui, peut-être aussi. Ouais, ouais,
ouais. Donc, mais voilà. Donc il a
raison, ça va pas se passer tout seul.
Je sais plus qui disait il y aura pas
d'écologiste en conflit. Oui, il va y
avoir des conflits mais si c'est
anticipé au plus haut niveau, si c'est
partagé avec le peuple, il y a de fortes
chances que ces conflits se passent
relativement douceur, même si mot
conflit et douceur sont pas vraiment
sont pas des des paradigmes qui sont
jumeaux. Mais mais oui, voilà, ça va se
passer comme ça. Mais il faut au moins
envisager la question. Aujourd'hui, ils
envisagent même pas la question. Ce que
je vous dis replanter des forêts, c'est
pas compliqué. Voilà, mais qui dit on va
replanter des forêts. Forêt c'est des
plu de carbone extraordinaire. Alors
étudions vraiment mais étudions où
replanter des forêts. Les vols
domestiques ils ont supprimé Orlie Brest
Orlie Bordeaux et Orlon mais ils ont
laissé Roy Brest Roy Bordeaux R c'est
des c'est des c'est des effets d'annonce
mais en pratique ils le font pas. Alors
après ils peuvent nous opposer mais
qu'est-ce que je fais des des 1000
personnes qui travaillent sur ces lignes
? Voilà ça oui le politique qui dit le
politique qu'on attend qui dit vous
inquiétez pas je vais m'occuper de vous
mais vraiment m'occuper de vous que dans
un an ces gens-l soient pas en train de
dire on est au chage on s'est pas occupé
nous qui s'occupe vraiment de qu'on a
suffisamment confiance
bref il y a des solutions voilà moi je
me suis je ne fais que commenter le
désarroie
de nos interviews vous avez regardé quoi
d'autre est-ce que vous avez regardé des
interviews de militaires de de
Ouais c'est souvent intéressant non
c'est souvent intéressant qu'est-ce que
j'ai vu j'ai bien aimé un banquier qui
parlait de de tool l'érance financière
je me rappelle plus de son nom mais c un
type ce type compétent Raphaël Rossello.
Oui, voilà. Hyper intéressant ce qu'il
racontait. Ouais, parce qu'on voit
quelqu'un qui sont dans le système mais
qui dit ça déconne. Voilà, ça c'est
vraiment intéressant. Ouais. Estce
qu'ils sont pas en train de le défendre
cont je suis vraiment dedans et puis
voilà ce qui va pas. Voilà. Et il y
avait une fois vous aviez associé trois
personnes, un un ancien homme d'affaires
Giro et puis encore un autre qui était
un prof de l'économie à Dauphine euh
militant gauchisiste qui avait tout le l
du gauchis, la barbe et le pantalon en
voulour côtelé qui était très
sympathique. Euh ils étaient tous les
trois sur un truc et c'était intéressant
sur voilà trois personnes de la société
civile très différente mais qui
partageaient le même point de vue.
Il a peut-être pas la barbe
enfin je sais pas enf il avait une
attitude enfin voilà je l'aurais
représenté au cinéma je l'urais présenté
comme ça ce personnage là ça me faisait
marrer quoi. portait son sa psiché sur
ses vêtements. Voilà. Et et c'était très
intéressant parce qu'il c'était des gens
différents. Un homme d'affaires qui av
fait plein de sous mais qui disait c'est
un peu con de continuer. Un gars qui
disait voilà ce qu'il faut faire. Giro
qui disait beaucoup d'intelligence des
choses intéressantes. Enfin voilà donc
oui il y en a il y a des solutions, il y
a des idées, il y a des personnes.
Et voter et emmener quelqu'un jusqu'au
second tour c'est une solution. Bah tel
que c'est présenté, nous en tant que
consommateur, on est sollicité 100 fois
par jour sur son sur sa tablette et par
contre en tant que en tant qu'électeur,
c'est une fois tous les 5 ans pour
quelqu'un qu'on nous présente et qu'on a
pas forcément choisi. Et
et donc voilà, c'est c'est c'est un truc
qui est un peu étrange et d'aller dans
un isolar qui est truc archaïque. On
faisait comme ça il y a 200 ans. Il y a
un truc rigolo. Cet été, ils ont demandé
à la mairie de Paris à dire on faire un
référendum. Là pour qu'il se risque à
faire un référendum, c'est que vraiment
ils sont sur deux [rires]
sinon il le ferait pas. Et donc il dit
faire sur les trottinettes. Alors
c'était un dimanche dans un isoloir, il
y a eu 97 % de l'abstention. Est-ce et
donc il pas de trottinette forcément
c'est des petits vieux qui sont déplacé
laborieusement pour aller voter et ils
ont dit non parce que ça leur fout les
jetons et une trottinette à juste titre
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être pas très bien
organisé mais bien évidemment tous les
gamins adorent les trottinettes et
veulent des trottinettes. Donc a priori
en septembre là il y aura plus de
trottinette et c mais c'est une connerie
c'est une des solutions la trottinette
mais la façon dont ça était présenté
soit-disant démocratique en pratique ça
l'était pas du tout. Donc qu'on soit, on
pourrait par exemple faire des des
expériences pilotes dans des villes,
dans des grandes villes, voilà euh le
conseil municipal de Lyon, de Bordeaux,
de je sais pas quoi, de de Rennes, de
Brest, bah on va faire une plateforme
numérique. Vous vous êtes euh électeur
de Bress, vous suivez de BR et ben
voilà, on va poser des questions. Euh
oui ou non une pistycle, des trucs
basiques de de vie de tous les jours.
Oui ou non pour les bus, oui ou non pour
une nouvelle école, oui ou non et cetera
et vous dites oui ou non. Et on jugerait
la qualité d'écoute du maire en fonction
du fait qu'il a écouté ou pas référendum
qui pourrait être hebdomadaire. Ça c'est
une façon démocratique de gouverner.
Alors souvent les gens qui disent "J'ai
entendu ça dans un dans un débat
référendum il y a des gens qui
voteraient pour la peine de mort et
c'est très simple de dire les acquis
historiques donc constitutionnellement
ne seront jamais posés dans un
référendum." C'est très simple à faire
ça. Il y a des mecs qui sont payés des
fortunes pour faire le le conseil des
sages. Ils peuvent très bien dire voilà
on peut leur demander en tout cas de le
faire. Tout ce qui est fait homosexuel
l'avortement tout ça on n'y touchera
pas. On viendra pas la suite hein. La ba
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ? Que ça
sorte à la rentrée alors que des profs
mal payés, il y a pas assez de profs
n'importe comment. On fait du speed
profing. Le Baya c'est une des
conséquences du commutarisme dont je
parlais. C'est c'est une des
conséquences du repus sur soi
identitaire. Absolument. Les gens les
gamins ne se retrouvent plus du tout
dans le monde dans il fréquentent. Puis
comme ils viennent d'origine autre que
que gauloise et ben ils se révoltent. Et
une façon de se révolter c'est la baaya.
Ce qui est pas une bonne solution que
l'école revendique sa la cité. Ça, je
trouve ça bien. La laïcité c'est une des
c'est une des bases de ce pays. Voilà,
la liberté d'expression laité c'est il y
a des gens sont morts pour qu'on ait la
laïcité. Il y a une loi qui a été voté
il y a 1904 je crois pour séparer
l'église et l'État. Les chrétiens nous
ont bien emmerdé pendant ces siècl pas
pour d'autres d'autres nous emmerder.
Donc c'est hyper important le quand les
mecs ils ont buté Charlie là. Ça m'a
bouleversé moi. Tout tout mec comme Camu
dont je disais le le grand Dudu pilote
c'est puis moi j'ai toujours été fier
d'appartenir à cette culture. J'étais
fier de d'avoir écouté Colu. J'étais
fier d'avoir d'écouter des proches quand
j'étais à l'école. J'étais fier que ces
gens puissent dire ça, ce qu'on pourrait
plus dire aujourd'hui d'ailleurs, j'ai
j'ai grandi avec ces gens-là et qu'on
atteigne cette parole là. C'est c'est
moi je trouve c'est terrible. Je pensais
nivement que le lendemain tous les jour
de France allaient aller publier les
fameux dessins qui d'ailleurs sont pas
du tout injurieux mais qui ont été
publiés par des Danois. Enfin bref non,
tout le monde a fermé sa gueule par la
pétoche. Une minorité peut [__] la
terreur. C'est le principe des nazis
hein. Une minorité a pris le pouvoir en
Allemagne, a foutu la terreur partout.
Donc alors la ba voilà moi je comprends
le désois des gamins mais je comprends
aussi le que l'école disent non ici
c'est chacun on oublie tout et la
religion c'est la meilleure façon de
dire à un enfant qu'il est différent
d'un autre c'est quêtement con vous
voyez moi j'étais chrétien malgré mo je
suis pas chrétien je suis agnostique
mais j'aime bien les églises partie de
ma culture. Je suis allé il y a pas
longtemps juste pour être au calme. Mais
je trouve ça vraiment très intéressant
et on devrait interdire la religion
jusqu'à 18 ans. Puis à 18 ans, on
devrait apprendre l'histoire des
religions. Ça c'est intéressant
l'histoire des religions. Pourquoi des
gens le doute de vivre c'est de trouver
exprimé dans dans des textes religieux ?
Souvent intéressant, il y a des sourates
magnifiques, il a des versets du nouveau
testament qui sont judicieux. Mais à 18
ans, on doit dire à l'enfant bah voilà,
choisis une religion. Si un texte fait
du bien, si une réunion te fait du bien,
alors vas-y qui que tu sois, d'où tu, on
s'en fout. Mais imprimer à ce cerveau
tout neuf avec la plasticité phénoménale
du cerveau enfantin, des dogmes
religieux qui sont que des dogmes, qui
sont des principes, bah ça je trouve ça
quasiment criminel. Moi il me faut
encore je fois je suis un bibé cette
[__] de [rires]
quand j'étais beau me on va pas
[grognement] des miracles. Bon les
miracles c'est une métaphore c'est
[rires]
et un jour donc en me bross sur les
dents je 7 8 ans j'étais au catéchisme
quand même. Voilà j' même été enfant
pour vous dire et puis l'eau froide est
devenue chaude.
[rires] J'ai d [__] miracle et si
c'est une catastrophe. Il va il va
falloir que je sois curé parce qu'il
voulait pas [rires] curé des pendant des
semaines. Ça m'a ronté cette histoire.
Le chaude est devenu le froide est
devenu chaude. J'ai gardé ça pour moi.
C'est un miracle que je garde pour moi
parce que sinon tu vas me dire miracle
il v [rires] dans ma salle de bain à
genou et puis je vais être curé. Voyez
c'est pour vous dire. Alors après j'ai
eu fortement envie de je m'en suis voulu
bien sûr mais j'avais 8 ans. Je me suis
pardonné mais je pardonne pas aux gens
qui m'ont fait croire à ces conneries.
Voyez, j'ai un copain qui est qui qui
est prêtre et qui m'a dit un jour qu'il
avait dit "Bon, les petits pains,
marcher sur l'eau, c'est des métaphores
et ben il y a des mecs qui attendaient
après le sermon pour lui dire ça a pas
métaphore, c'est pas vrai, ça s'est
fait." Quand on montre dans l'histoire,
le Nouveau Testament, c'est 300 ans
après la mort de Jésus, c'est un
concile. C'est Constantin qui dit
l'empereur Constantin qui dit "Moi, je
veux être chrétien." Et il demande à des
gens d'écrire le Nouveau Testament. Et
comme on parle d'une religion
polythéiste et une religion monothéiste
et bah il faut bien qu'il y ait des
miracles, faut bien que Jésus qui est un
qui est un penseur, on dire aujourd'hui
un penseur, un mec intelligent qui est
certainement venu he qui a dit choses
présentes, ça
aurait été un grand scénariste
certainement mais il faut qu'il soit
soit le fils d'un dieu. Voilà et c'est
là où c'est contestable donc il a fait
des miracles. C'est là où on infantise
la pensée humaine dans la religion. On
l'infantise complètement.
Le politique qui participe aussi
l'infantilisation
bien sûr le politique qui se sert de la
enfin comme le religieux d'ailleurs le
religieux se sert de la peur de vivre.
Et le politique se sert de la peur de
l'existence. Il y a une vraie
différence. Euh vivre c'est des
émotions. Exister c'est le quotidien.
Voyez vivre c'est grand. Exister des
fois c'est médiocre et petit. C'est
boire manger, copuler, chercher du
travail et c'est c'est Newton. Moi
j'aime bien compagnie de Rimo. Voyez ?
Alors Rabu il vous pas il fait pas
manger voyez. Mais là il y a beaucoup de
Newton dans le monde dans lequel on vit.
On est tous censés être des bêtes de
consommation et des bêtes de compétition
sociale. Or pourtant l'enfance, il y a
une très jolie phrase de par Dieu dans
un bouquin qu'il a écrit qui s'appelle
ailleur je crois qui dit que la vraie
violence [grognement] c'est tout ce qui
atteint la poésie de l'enfant mais c'est
très juste. Voilà l'enfant il est
créatif, il est il est il est inventif,
il il est vraiment en dialogue avec avec
RB. Moi j'ai des enfants donc je me
régale de leur compagnie. Des fois je
suis épaté de de cette imagination et
puis on les met à l'école. Là c'est la
rencontre avec Newton. On nous apprend à
participer à un système collectif
extérieur et un système qui est
complètement de plus en plus déviant.
C'est ce qu'on voit. Et on on prône
l'alphabétisation beaucoup plus que la
créativité. C'est la créativité qui nous
en sortira de de de cette de cette
transhumance suicidaire pour pour
évoquer votre votre terme.
C'est votre terme ?
Oui. Enfin bon, vous l'avez vous l'avez
pour préd mais c'est ça c'est la la Vous
avez vu des gens ici sont qui sont qui
sont créatifs dans l'économie, il sont
créatifs dans dans les solutions
écologiques. Oui. Oui. Faut pas baisser
les bras. Pas du tout.
les les les politiques, l'écum des
choses, les politiques, les sujets
infantilisants.
Est-ce que c'est vous l'analysez comment
? C'est c'est une perte de repère, c'est
une impuissance,
c'est le fait qu'il faut continuer à
brasser du vent et à scè ils ont été mis
ils ont été mis en place pour avoir le
pouvoir, pour pédagogiser les masses,
pour expliquer les bienfaits de la
mondisation parce que les gens qui les
ont mis au pouvoir sont des gens qui ont
tout intérêt à ce que la mondisation
continue. Vous comprenez ? pense même
qu'ils vont s'en sortir par rapport au
réchauffement climatique. Il paraît
qu'ils achètent des terres en Norvège,
je sais pas où, ce qui paraît-il être
assez naïf. Donc voilà, ils font leur
boulot mais le boulot, leur boulot,
c'est pas vraiment notre vie et on est
de plus en plus en décalage par rapport
à eux. Eux, je pense que eux-mêmes
doivent même pas comprendre des fois
pourquoi on l' en veut. Voyez, il y a
des choses simples à faire. Il y a des
choses des discours, des propos à tenir,
je les ai évoqué là, les températures,
les choses, mais c'est pas ça qu'on
entend. On entend parler de PIB,
d'indice de croissance, de compétition,
de start-up nation, de
de guerre
et puis malheureusement de guerre.
Ouais. Et là c'est une des raisons du
succès de cet excellent film d'ailleurs
Openheimer. Je vous recommande, j'ai vu
des gamins avec le pop-corn écouter des
des dialogues sur la physique quantique
et Nisbourg parce que le film en parle.
Je trouvais ça super. Voilà voilà voilà.
Un grand film qui qui pédagogise
intelligemment les gamins pour leur dire
voilà. Et pourquoi ils sont intéressés ?
puisque on leur parle beaucoup de guerre
de guerre atomique notamment et encore
une fois on leur parle intelligemment
d'un sujet qui les touche et
intelligemment et brillamment Nolan
c'est pas c'est pas vraiment chaud et
donc voilà donc là on parle on parle on
on leur parle de guerre ça fout les
jetons et parce que même si la Corée du
Nord se bat avec le Japon je sais pas ou
quelque part là-bas forcément on en aura
les conséquences à un nuage atomique qui
fera le tour de la terre alors
si la Russie bombe l'Ukraine ou
inversement je je je sais pas c'est
tristement possible al je vous
recommande après bon est-ce que
l'Occident Sinon à chaque fois et le
chevalier servant. Non, l'Occident
génère souvent son son propre désastre.
Qu'est-ce que les Américains sont allés
[__] en Irak ? On se le demande encore
aujourd'hui. Ça a généré la naissance de
Daesh et avec les conséquences en France
qui pour une fois était le seul pays
intelligemment qui était pas allé se
mêler à cette colonisation violente.
Voilà. Donc vous dit euh moi je suis
Ouais, je suis comme vous les guerres.
La prochaine encore une fois Einstein
qui disait que la 4e guerre mondiale se
fera avec des bâtons et des pierres
parce que la 3è il y aura pas beaucoup
de survivant.
Il y en avait un autre qui disait que la
guerre c'était l'extinction de la
politique par d'autres moyens.
Ouais. Enfin, la politique très con
parce que il y a pas plus con que la
guerre. Ça c'est difficile de faire
mieux quoi. Tu as tellement bout
d'arguments que qu'on décide de
s'entretuer d'aller chercher des gens
qui ne se sont rien fait. Mon grand-père
fait était paysan en Bretagne puis il
est allé tuer. Il a avoué à mon père à
la fin de sa vie qu'il est dans la
bagarre la guerre de 14. Il a dû tuer
quelqu'un.
Votre génération, elle a connu tous ses
grands films pendant la guerre froide.
Ouais. Euh on génération, c'est pas
comme si j'étais un vieillard. Vous
m'aiderez pour ressortir du fauteuil
après. Je compte je compte sur vous les
jeunes.
Quand on voit une réhtorique de guerre
froide et réémerger comme ça, que ce
soit chez eux, chez nous et ailleurs.
Je vais vous dire un truc. L'empire
soviétique, il avait une vertu, c'est
qu'il faisait flipper les capitalistes
et il incitait au partage. Le jour où le
blanc, bon c'était une des rares vertus,
hein. Le reste, les gens, ils ont morflé
sévère mais le jour où il s'est
effondré, la modélisation a explosé. Le
choix qui était fait dans une équine de
marché régulée, intelligente et mixte,
on va dire, a été explosé par rapport à
la folie consumériste qui qui fait qui
fait la joie, des Lon Musk, des baiseau,
et compagnie, c'est fou. Il y a 10
personnes, je crois, qui possèdent
l'équivalent de la moitié de la richesse
du monde. Euh, votre ministre de
l'économie, le maire 10 ans pendant le
confinement, je me suis arrangé avec
Amazon, on aura le droit au Black
Friday. Voyez, qu'est-ce que le Black
Friday vient [__] dans notre culture,
nom de Dieu ? [rires] On s'en fout voir
des gens s'arracher des t-shirts
fabriqués par des momes qui au lieu
d'aller à l'école font ça en Asie. C'est
triste quand même bordel. C'est triste
quoi. Et et voyez le parler de politique
horsol, il a pas conscience de ça le
mec. Il devrait dire lui bien sûr il lui
faut ses chiffres, il faut sa taxe
professionnelle, il faut ses impôts, il
lui faut grossir son fameux PIB mais il
faut raisonner autrement. Le Black
Friday c'est de la connerie. On peut pas
transformer un individu en consommateur.
C'est pas possible. Encore une fois,
même les laïques ont besoin de
spiritualité. Moi, je suis laïque, mais
je crois qu'il y a autre chose au-dessus
de nous. Il suffit de regarder un ciel
étoilé le soir, même les pieds dans le
bitume près d'un fast food ou d'un
parking ou d'un métro pourri. On
appartient aux étoiles, on appartient
pas à ce qu'on a créé nous qui est qui
est encore une fois l'emprise de Newton.
Voyez, je sais pas si je suis très
clair. Vous me dites vous êtes perdu.
Non non les jeunes.
En terme de film de regarder les
étoiles, est-ce que un film de de
science-fiction qui vous a
Je suis pas fan de science-fiction puis
il faut en savoir-faire. Bon moi je je
sais faire que mes films, je vous le dis
en toute en toute modestie. Des fois,
c'est de la science-fiction,
[grognement]
c'est la science-fiction romanesque mais
c'est pas la science-fiction au sens
technique du terme. Les grands metteurs
en scène, les cubriques, les spilber.
Oui, ils sont tellement grands, ils sont
tellement géniaux qu'ils peuvent toucher
à tous les tous les domaines. Moi, je je
je j'arrive à être relativement clair
sur un domaine ménévrose, voilà, c'est
une catégorie beaucoup plus modeste. Je
joue en division d'honneur pour prendre
une référence footballistique pour que
tout le monde comprenne bien. Mais non,
non, voilà. Mais mais mais la SF ouais
moi Blade Runner le premier mo le
deuxième j'ai trouvé trop long mais
formidable Alien Red Scott l'ouverture
de enfin moi je suis voilà je en tant
que consommateur de film moi je bibronne
bibronne minorité ripod speedberg grand
grand grand bouquin de cadic et puis
grand film de speedberg quoi. Mais for
ça je suis pas sûr.
Le gouvernement lequel lequel est le
plus hors sol le plus extraterrestre ?
Bah ils sont ils sont nombreux. Nous, on
est pas mal en France quand même, on
s'en sort bien. Il y a eu une réunion il
y a pas longtemps ministériel. Je crois
qu'ils ont très peu parlé d'écologie. Ça
les dérange pas de de transpirer par 30
degrés au mois de septembre, mais ils
ont autre chose. Ils sont dans une dans
un réseau
été indien.
Oui, on va dire ça. Mais alors, il est
très été, pas trop pas trop indien. Mais
ils sont dans un dans un ils voient plus
les choses dans leur tête que dans la
réalité. Ils sont dans un dans des
schémas idéologiques, y compris les les
les financiers, les économistes dans une
dans une idéologie, il il voi plus leur
leur leur oui leur leur idéologie que la
réalité. C'est très étonnant. Le bateau
cool, on leur dit ça cool, mais on verra
ça plus tard. Pour l'instant, on a des
trucs à régler avec le casino qui est en
cours. On dit vous êtes en train de
jouer avec les pièces du bateau là. On
verra ça plus tard.
Le plus tard, c'est quoi ? C'est
l'argent magique. C'est je suis
tellement à fond que si je je ne fais
pas ça, le monde s'écroule. C'est c'est
c'est des convictions qu'ils ont qu'on
leur qu'on leur a inculqué. Un gamin qui
aujourd'hui qui est brillant, il va
faire quoi une école de commerce ?
Est-ce que c'est ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui une école de commerce ? Il y
a pas longtemps là sur Adieu les cons,
un gamin qui a fait une école de
commerce qui s'occupe de notre film pour
les ventes à l'étranger nous appelle en
disant voilà Émiré ses Qatars ont acheté
le film dans les avions mais ils veulent
supprimer la scène de l'église.
La scène de
de l'église.
Ah
alors je dis bah attends non déjà le
film a plus beaucoup de sens et tout
puis quand même c'est un peu choquant
trouve pas. Enfin, tu vois, moi ça me
dérange pas de filmer mosquée, je m'en
fous si j'ai besoin pour mon film, c'est
pas c'est pas le problème. Et il me dit
"Bah, le problème, c'est qu'on va perdre
40000 €." Donc ce raisonnement sincère
et et et juste, c'est que s'il faut
cogner des sous. Et c'est extrêmement
comme ça qu'aujourd'hui l'Occident est
prêt faire n'importe quoi pour toucher
des sous des regardez les mecs qui on
parler du foot, mec qui font du foot,
les grands les grands joueurs de foot.
Bon là, il y en a un français, je me
rappelle pas le nom, qui est très fort
et cetera, qui part à la retraite. Il
part la retraite où ? en Arabie
Saoudite. Voilà quelqu'un qui est pour
gagner encore plus de sous hein, je vais
refaire du foot et cetera dans un
championnat qui qui n' absolument pas
lieu d'être le chef là-bas, il a coupé
ses opposants en rondelle, je crois, un
journaliste en rondelle et puis il y a
pas longtemps, il y a un mec qui a coûté
qui était pas d'accord, je crois qu'il
est condamné à [rires]
donc ce qu'on retenu ce qu'on retenu ce
footballeur formé dans nos démocraties
parasport qui a été inventé par une
démocratie même si ces démocraties,
elles sont loin d'être parfaites, mais
malgré tout, il y a des filières pour
faire du football, il y a des
pédagogues, il y a des éducations, il y
a la liberté d'expression et cetera. Ils
font des grandes carrières.
Et à la retraite, c'est pas d'aller
remettre l'eau dans le puit qui les a
formé, c'est d'aller gagner encore plus
de soyeilleurs. Ce qu'ils ont retenu de
ce parcours, c'est l'argent. C'est un
échec, non ? C'est un échec de la
démocratie. La seule valeur qu'on leur
inculqué finalement, c'est ça. Le talent
qui était leur à l'arrivée, il cherche
qu'al moné et les gamins de les cités
qui arrivent de foot, il arrivent
surtout du salaire des footballeurs
parce que je pense que c'est dur d'être
un sportif de haut niveau.
Il faut être un asset pour inspirer.
[grognement]
Un asset non, mais il faut remettre les
choses à la à leur place. Aujourd'hui,
si vous êtes d'accord, c'est dédirance
qui est en train de se passer. Les
salaires des Moi, je je je paidais la
cause pour pour ma nounou là pour
trouver 80000 €, mais c'est rien pour
eux, c'est prix de la bagnole, même pas
la bagnole de leur femme de ménage, vous
voyez et c'est ça qui est absurde. On a
perdu les valeurs, on a perdu les
repères et quand vous parlez des
politiques bah oui, effectivement, il ne
raisonne. Il raison aussi, ils ont été
mis en place pour ça, ils raisonnent
encore pour ça, même si tout autour ça
craque les gilets jaunes, le Covid, la
canicule, c'est on verra ça plus tard.
Pour l'instant, il s'agit de Oui, voilà.
Il s dit on parle d'inflation de machin
et cetera et ils sont vraiment dans des
problèmes quand la 5e République a été a
été faite les les les c'était des idées
politiques très forte il fallait que
l'économie suive aujourd'hui les idées
d'abord on demande si si Bercier est
d'accord voyez on voudrait faire ça
mettre les avions domestiques au sol
parce que ça pollue et cetera on
voudrait au moins lancer cette idée la
France c'est un petit pays a beaucoup
d'idées ah merci dit non c'est pas
possible vous allez mettre machin les
lobby qui vendent du kérosen vont faire
la gueule les person on peut pas alors
on peut pas je me fais laquer du diable
Ouais.
Bah si on fait ça nous petite France sur
l'hôtel de la mondialisation, va se
faire dépesser. Je Oui, je comprends
qu'il raisonne comme ça. C'est vrai que
là, j'arrête, j'arrête j'arrête de
courir. Est-ce que vous arrêtez de
courir aussi ?
Et en Europe, personne veut le faire. Et
puis les gens qui nous dirigent encore
une fois, sont des gens qui sont, je
crois qu'en Angleterre, c'est un
banquier aussi qui dirige le richiss
[grognement] oui. Voilà, ça c'est clair.
Il y a une prise de conscience qui doit
vraiment gén ils ont ils ont des mots,
ils ont des termes, ils ont des
déclarations, mais on voit bien que dans
les faits, c'est pas ça qui va qui va
s'arrêter de courir
qu'on est déjà en guerre. Alors qu'on
est des gens en guerre et qu' déjà en
train de couler et qu'on se prend le
mur, il é 1 m le mur.
Avec l'Amérique ça arrête de courir. Le
problème c'est que le le rêve
pr de vie des Américains n'est pas
négociable.
Le ça c'est c'est Bouche qui avait dit
ça. Ouais. À Kyoto les accords les a pas
signé à cause de ça quoi. Mais le le
rêve américain c'est le cauchemar de
l'humanité.
Le rêve américain avec les greles, les
bitumes, les jets, c'est le l'humanité
peut pas supporter ça. La terre peut pas
supporter ça. Et elle nous dit depuis 10
ans, depuis puis ça va pas s'arrêter.
Arrêtez, j'en peux plus, j'étouffe.
Arrêtez vos conneries. Donc si si
l'existence humaine, si la vie humaine a
a un sens, bah oui, il faut c'est moment
de le trouver.
C'est peut-être le moment de trouver les
bons politique. Ah, je sais même pas si
mot politique, voyez, moi quand je pense
politique, je pense je pense à Grandi,
je pense à Mandela. Oui, c'est des
hommes politiques mais bon, vous avez vu
ce qu'on en a fait déjà, on les a au
butés ou mis en tô là mais c'est des
haut de conscience. Bah, c'est ce qu'il
faut, c'est des gens qui ont une haute
conscience. Ce qu'on appelle la
sociocratie de la haute conscience.
Faudrait que nous, électeurs, pas
électeur citoyens, on désigne quelqu'un.
et nous voudrait lui du Pontel président
[rires]
une catastrophe. J'ai j'ai mais vraiment
il y a moi bon je je suis ferru de pas
mal de trucs et dans le film à moment
donné je parle du professeur Jacob
professeur Jacob c'est le nom que je
donne à une un prix Noël de médecin il a
vraiment existé et quand j'étais en
médecine un des rares personnages de la
médecine qui m'intéressait c'était ce
professeur Jacob qui était un gars qui a
découvert l'N parce queavant qu'il y a
la reine messager il bien fallu que des
gens découvrent l'ARN on connaissait
l'ADN on connaissait pas l'ARN donc avec
trois avec Minkowski Mono et Jacob c'est
trois médecins qui ont découvert la RN
qui pris ben les années 60 et je crois
que c'est le père d'ailleurs de
l'éditrice Audit de Jacob je crois et il
a écrit un bouquin s'appelle la statue
intérieure et un jour un journaliste lui
dit "Mais qu'est-ce que alors vous qui
savez tout c'est quand même un pu de
science qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
pourriez dire et cetera puis il dit bah
le problème c'est que au printemps
chaque fois c'est pas jardin de
Luxembourg les armes ont des fleurs. Je
peux pas vous expliquer pourquoi il y a
le printemps pourquoi ça vient c'est que
même lui reconnaissait que que que c'est
pour moi la trace d'une immense sagesse.
Voilà le gars qui dit "Je suis censé
savoir tout en fait, je ne sais rien."
Et et quand vous parlez de politique
hors sol, bah il y a il y a une il y a
une arrogance chez ces gens qui au lieu
de nous dire humblement Merkel l'a fait
une fois une fois s excusé, elle a dit
"Excusez-moi, je crois j'ai merdé je
sais plus sur quel sujet mais je
trouvais ça vraiment ça grandit le
personnage, faut pas croire mais eux ils
disent non s'est pas trompé." Ils disent
une chose son contraire, ils se plantent
mais non mais si vous avez mal compris
qui aurait pu prédire
oui qui aurait pu prédire la canicule
fait 35 ans enf on on me disait covid
enfin on per desépidémie de il a dû
sauter des cours Macron c'est pas
possible quand même. Donc donc oui mais
ils sont dans une mais
Macron il est pas tout seul.
Non mais je sais bien mais il écoute pas
forcément. Moi, j'ai un pote qui est
devenu un très grand médecin. Lui, il a
vraiment continué brillamment sa
carrière et à l'époque du Covid, il
était proche du conseil scientifique et
il me disait qu'ils écoutaient pas du
tout ce que disait le conseil
scientifique. Donc ça, ça c'est une
expression très claire de la de la de la
de la frénésie en cours. Effectivement,
c'est comme pour le le vide dont vous
parlez tout à l'heure de votre ministre
qui disait qu'il va y avoir un vide.
Euh, [grognement]
on ne parle même pas d'arrêter la
course. C'est qu'il y a même pas de de
concertation en Europe, par exemple,
pour dire nous en Europe, on va tenter
la décroissance. Je sais pas si c'est le
bon mot la décroissance, mais on va se
calmer. Il il y a même pas ça.
Oui, nous nous on tente même pas la
décroissance, on tente la déconsommation
des consommateurs
il s'est même pas évoqué publiquement.
Donc nous ce qu'on peut déjà dire mais
est-ce que vous pourriez pas évoquer ce
sujet-là ? Mais évoquer vraiment pas
avec des RC dont on enterre après les
solutions qui souvent sont vraiment
intéressantes. Cette absence de parole
le hors sol c'est quoi ? C'est des gens
qui parlent d'un truc qui nous préoccupe
pas et d'être au quotidien préoccupé par
des soucis évidents climatiques et et
sociaux. Vous
vous intéressez toujours au système de
santé ?
Bah je préfère ça que la santé
s'intéresse à moi. [rires]
Je suis encore en bonne forme. Euh bah
ouais, il y avait un médecin et puis qui
je crois qu'il était viré. Non, il s a
un autre maintenant qui qui a la santé.
Je crois qu' il y avait un médecin,
c'est une bonne idée de mettre un
médecin à la santé. Puis je crois qu'il
il était peut-être pas assez politique,
ils en ont foutu un autre. Voilà, c'est
ce que j'ai suivi. Et ce que je vois à
mon niveau, c'est le désert médical.
Ouais. Tusimut. Alors, si je me faisais
l'avocat du diable comme vous en passant
par l'économie, je dirais voilà,
proposons aux jeunes médecins une
défiscalisation. pendant 5 ans si vous
installez dans les endroits où il y a
pas de médecin parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
coupez le doigt dans les semaines faut
faut j'espère qu'il y aura pas
d'hémorragie que vous serez mort avant
d'arriver [rires] avant d'arriver chez
le tub et c'est vraiment dommage quoi
puisqueen plus ça crée du lien social un
médecin c'est c'est c'est c'est
phénoménal la relation qui met les
comment il peut apaiser les gens comment
il peut leur parler comment il peut
avoir des bonnes infos
comme le postier
exactement mais même le mec qui relève
l'électricité mais attends on peut il
faut prendre la photo. Moi j'ai pas le
temps, je suis pas là alors je peux pas
faire la photo. Donc il m'aligne. J'ai
reçu [rires]
NG 1600 € d'électricité pour cet été.
J'étais pas chez moi
parce que j'ai pas fait la photo. Une
fois je l'ai fait puis ça ça a buggé. Je
suis pas arrivé quand même. Mais faut
pas déconner les mecs. Si on pouvait
piloter les avions nous-mêmes et puis
faut pour chercher le pétrole, il nous
le demanderait. Donc il y a
un peu comme dans les supermarchés quand
on doit faire le ticket.
Voilà, c'est dommage de papoter avec la
caissière, c'est intéressant. Puis ça
donne du boulot aussi à des gens comme
ça. Donc on ar 1984, Rel Ouais, il était
vraiment visionnaire au Brésil pour
reciter ce film culte pour moi.
Je suis optimiste.
Ouais ouais. Non mais il en fautin. Il
faut accepter de
que certains ne portent pas les mêmes
lunettes roses que les autres.
Ouais. Enfin on est plein comme ça. Si
on veut pas les porter, c'est tout.
Quand quand quand la promesse politique
quand on deviendra ridicule,
c'est que quand les décisions politiques
ou le la parole politique, on deviendra
tellement ridicule, qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ?
On sera ridicule quand on sera mort.
Ce qui risque de se passer. Tant qu'on
est vivant, on n'est pas ridicule. Il y
a des solutions. Maintenant, alors
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Voilà. Moi
moi j'ai très peur de 2027 parce que on
m'aurait dit un vieux de ma génération,
on aurait dit il y a 40 ans que
l'extrême droite serait aussi présente
dans la vie politique, je l'aurais pas
cru. Et je me rappelle de des proches
recevant Le Pen dans les années 80 don
j'étais encore à l'école et je je
hurlais de rire parce que le type était
un parenton de ridicule et de de
simplicité et cetera et cetera et des
proches et RGO avaient été absolument
épat [rires]
mais j'aurais jamais imaginé que ces
descendants aient une telle influence
aujourd et et puis il se comporte bien
costard cravat un mot plus haut que
l'autre donc tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est une gesticulation
dangereuse c'est une arrogance
dangereuse c'est des gens hors sol et
qui sont en train de faire le lit de de
de ces raisonnements simplistes et
dangereux. Et la gauche dans son
hystérie aussi stupide
ne
n'arrange pas les choses. Il y a pas
vraiment de de leader. Il y a un mec à
la France assoumise, une députée je
crois qu' a dit "Je ne suis pas
Charlie." Quand on est député de la
France, on peut pas dire "Je ne suis pas
Charlie." C'est pas possible. Donc ça
m'a ça m'a éloigné définitivement de de
ces gens-là. Donc il y a certainement
une personnalité qui soit à la fois
énergique, convaincue et puis
consensuelle parce qu'aujourd'hui dont
on a besoin c'est vraiment l'union
nationale. On a pas besoin de se [__]
sur la gueule comme ça se passe à
l'Assemblée. Les les les gens ils sont
payés pour pour débattre pas pour se
battre et des quelques fois je tombe sur
des l'effet d'hiver à l'assine nationale
c'est vraiment constant quoi. Ah ouais
c'est dommage. C'est vraiment dommage.
Il y a de l'intelligence dans ce pays.
Il y a de la sagesse. Il y a il y a a du
génie. Il y a le génie français. Ouais
vraiment mais tant qu'il s'exprime mais
c'est pas avec eux que ça va se passer.
C'est sûr. Voilà. Alors, voyez des
films, allez dans les musées, voyez des
tableaux, faites du sport, vélo dans la
nature, s'il en reste.
Je vais prendre une question, pas
internet, mais une question quand même.
[raclement de gorge]
Est-ce que aujourd'hui le cinéma, la
fabrique du récit est une vraie
importance pour l'éducation du public
quant à quant au sujets politiques,
écologique et cetera ? On en est où dans
le cinéma français ?
Alors, le cinéma français, c'est un très
grand cinéma. Les français inventé le
cinéma dans les années 30. Il y a 100
ans, le premier distributeur au monde
c'était pâté.
Euh, il y a un très grand cinéma des
années 30 qui a toujours une conscience
sociale. Le Front populaire s'est
beaucoup exprimé par le cinéma des
années 30 de chez Renoir passant par
carnet du vivier et cetera et tout. Moi,
j'adore ce cinéma. À titre personnel, le
cinéma est devenu aujourd'hui même au
niveau européen euh au niveau européen,
il est devenu une plateforme une
plateforme parmi d'autres. Voilà, c'est
ça qui est dommage. Ma génération, il y
avait trois chaînes de télé, le cinéma
était très important. C'était un lieu où
on pouvait aller et voir des images du
son sur grand écran. Aujourd'hui, il y a
des plateformes numériques dans laquelle
je bibronne, hein. Je je je moi j'ai
Netflix et cetera, je vais biberonner,
mais on a un choix de contenu
phénoménaux et et donc le cinéma est une
des plateformes n'est plus qu'une des
plateformes de de d'expression
audiovisuelle
pour ma génération et même quand je le
succès d'ophimer et les gamins qui vont
donc c'est pas perdu. C'est pas perdu.
Donc c'est une expression, je trouve
élégante pour raconter bah les désarrois
d'un auteur ou les commentaires sur le
monde qu'on est en train de traverser.
C'est une c'est une expression
grandiose, c'est un grand écran, c'est
du son, c'est une expression artisanale.
On travaille beaucoup sur les lumières,
sur le son, sur la musique. Donc c'est
une expression totale quand vous faites
un film en vous impliquant totalement.
La couleur,
la couleur bien évidemment, tout. Alors
après, il y a différents niveaux de
film. Il y a le film d'auteur pur et dur
mais qui est intéressant. Moi je suis un
fan de Kenlot. Je je je je encore des
souvenirs violents de Lady Bird, de
films comme ça qui tout d'un coup vous
raconte des choses d'une telle justesse,
d'une telle émotion qu'on sort de là
effectivement indigné d'y est arrivé
puis il y a des films grand public comme
je vous parlais de Dopheor qui racontent
aussi des choses passionnantes mais
d'une autre façon plus plus plus plus
consommable et puis a des petits petits
films comme moi je fais et puis et
cetera donc c'est c'est un c'est un
c'est un c'est un mode d'expression que
je trouve qui qui peut amener une
certaine forme d'élégance et je vous dis
ça en ayant Faberni qui est pas vraiment
forcément toujours très élégant
Mais c'est une façon élégante de
raconter un désarrois trash. Voilà.
Fais-moi le malin là.
Oui, fais-moi le malin. Voilà.
Effectivement
euh quand vous voyez l'intelligence
artificielle débarquer,
euh l'intelligence artificielle qui va
être peut-être capable de faire des
scénarios. Ah
ouais, je sais, j'ai entendu parler de
ça. Ouais.
Alors
bah je sais pas Wency,
euh
le numérique et les effets spéciaux, je
m'appuie beaucoup dessus. Donc moi quand
dans dans second tour quand il y a 10000
figurants à l'image, j'ai tourné avec
300. Quand il y a des parkings super et
tout ça, j'ai tourné en studio quoi. Une
voiture qui explose. Bon, j'ai fait une
grosse je l'ai fait pour de vrai mais en
studio avec des fonds verts et cetera.
Oui, je m'appuie quand même beaucoup de
ça pour faire mes petits récits après se
substituer
euh euh je sais pas mais c'est c'est
grave he ce qui se passe parce que c'est
vrai qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui des
scénarios écrits. Il est probable que
dans quelques années, on ait des acteurs
morts qui puissent interpréter des
films. Il y a des débats entre les
héritiers si on peut récupérer le droit
à l'image de de Gabin par exemple et
puis si on leur le scénario, les
descendants disent "Oui, je suis
d'accord."
Et un scénario écrit avec le le style
d'Albert Dupontel quand il sera mort.
Ben s'ils le disent pas, ça se verra
peut-être pas puisqu'on a toujours les
influences des uns et des autres. Après
euh le chat, je je sais pas, j'ai vu
quelques scénarios du chat GPT, c'est
c'est vraiment pas probant pour
l'instant, mais Kasparov disait voilà,
je je seraiis jamais battu par un
ordinateur, puis il a été battu par
l'ordinateur quand même. Donc euh oui
oui, c'est c'est c'est un vrai problème.
C'est un vrai problème ça.
Est-ce que vous avez entendu parler du
concept de guerre cognitive ?
Euh ça doit avoir un rapport avec
l'internet mais je pas pas précisément.
c'est manipuler les émotions des gens
pour les envoyer ou là là où on veut ou
c'est principe c'est le principe de la
publicité de toute façon on vous frustre
et cetera mais la publicité elle est
perverse si vous voulez on vous vend une
bagnole voilà il y a des voitures de de
de père de famille de fille qui qui a
marqué 220 au compteur à quoi ça sert on
n pas le droit de dépasser le 130 ils
sont en train de de protester contre la
légalisation du cannabis qui va avoir
lieu d'ailleurs je pense en Allemagne où
les verrs étant moins politisés sont
plus présents dans la vie politique. pas
forcément inintéressant. Mais le le si
vous voulez le paradoxe, c'est qu'en
France, on a le droit d'avoir de
l'alcool dans les stations service et
par contre on légalise pas le cannabis.
Pourquoi par exemple une ville pourrait
comme Marseille pourrait pas dire on va
tenter une espérance pilote de coffee
shop parce que les mecs s'entretuent
dans les cités à la Kalesnikov pour une
barrette de cheit. Est-ce qu'on pourrait
pas faire des coffee shop à Marseille
expérience pilote pendant 6 mois ? On va
voir s'il a délinquant de chut si c'est
moins dangereux. Voyons essayons.
L'argument c'est le le les dealers vont
se positionner sur d'autres types de
toujours des arguments pour pas faire
des choses. Le trou d'air on fait rien
parce qu'il va yir un trou d'air le le
le G du cannabis ça être encore pire.
Non c'est pas vrai. C'est déjà pire. Les
mecs s'entretuent. Vous avez vu le
nombre de de enfin Marseille c'est
dangereux comme quartier.
C'est pas une forme de sédation de
Si si on brandit le pire pour ne rien
faire. Retentez-vous de ça. On va
s'adapter le climat. On va s'adapter.
Non on va pas s'adapter on va en crever
et puis il y a des solutions. Voilà.
Voilà. Genre c'est un grand débat. Je
suis pour les coffee shop à Marseille.
Voilà.
Et on dit sans arrê ça que c'est
addictif et cetera. Mon gamin il a fait
un masters un masters universitaire à
Amsterdam, il a fumé des pétards. Il est
pas rentré toxico. Voyez, j'ai fumé des
pétards. Moi, moi j'ai une
spondilartrite. Alors, c'est une maladie
douloureuse depuis 30 ans qui me qui me
tracasse le corps. Et mon médecin m'a
dit "C'est mieux un peu d'herbe que le
tramadol." Tramadol, il bousille le foie
quand j'ai mal. Alors, j'ai plus souvent
du tramadol que de l'herbe. Alors, je
prends du tramadol. C'est pas bon ça.
Partir vivre en Suisse.
Ouais. Enfin, non, mais je suis bien en
France. J'aime ce pays quoi. Mais c'est
vrai que c'est c'est un pays, c'est une
terre de paradoxe, c'est de contraste.
Tout le monde s'engueule. Le français un
problème c'est qu'il aime pas le
français. Ça il a qu'à voir ça. La
défaite au 40 si les français s'étaient
aimés, ça aura jamais été battu par les
Allemands. [rires]
Et je lis pas mal de bouquins sur les
français à Londres, ils ont passé leur
temps à se [__] sur la gueule quand
même. De disait je sais pas quoi, je
gouverne des débiles un peu comme avait
dit Ellisabeth Born, je crois. C'est
c'est terrible quoi. C'est difficile.
C'est c'est marrant. C'est de les
Guelois, ils étaient plus nombreux à les
dire, faut le savoir. Ils étaient plus
nombreux que les Romains. Ils ont réussi
à perdre quand même. Donc c'est vraiment
un mal français quoi. Le français
parce que les Romains, les Romains les
ont emmené dans la forêt,
ils ont pas pu utiliser leur char,
ils se sont organisés et cetera mais les
gaulois étaient étaient un peuple
désordonnés. Bah il y a quel
Non non non mais dans dans c'est faut
dire Gosini quoi. Mais il semblerait que
les tribus soient foutu sur la gueule
sur la stratégie adoptée. Puis arrivé
les Romains qui étaient moins nombreux
ont quand même gardé Alésia et puis ils
ont ils ont étouffé ce pauvre
Vercalatorx.
Gosini, c'est pas mal. Question
internet. Bonjour. Quel serait le mode
de scrutin qui vous ferait revenir vers
les urnes ?
Bah moi j'aimerais bien le vote blanc.
Voilà, je crois c'est une façon
pacifiste de protester. Il y a des
candidats et puis si le vote blanc est
majoritaire et ben on s'excuse mais
avoir fait les élections, c'est que le
peuple ne veut pas de ces gens-là. Et je
pense que le vote blanc aurait gagné
Chirac Le Pen vote blanc, on aurait
recommencé les élections avec d'autres
gens. Après le pouvoir dit "Vous êtes
gentil, ça coûte de l'argent, c'est la
démocratie. vous sort un texte
institutionnel comme qu'on a pas le
droit. S'ils savent, ils se protègent.
Mais ouais, le vote blanc, moi je je
quand je me retrouve avec Macron Le Pen,
je voudrais voter blanc. Chirac le Pen,
je voudrais voter blanc et que si ce
vote et qu'on le prenne en compte, il y
aid des politiques on qui le prendra en
compte, pas un vote mineur si c'est
majeur, ça veut dire que les gens ne
veulent vraiment pas de ce vote là, de
cette élection là. Ils veulent pas de
ces joueursl, on en veut d'autres.
Voilà, ça serait pas mal ça.
Les Jeux Olympiques, ça a encore du
sens.
Bah, si on fait référendum il y a un an,
est-ce que vous voulez les Jeux
Olympiques en France ? Je pense la
réponse aurait été non. Donc ça va
coûter beaucoup de sous, ça va polluer
pour des pauvres gars qui souvent sont
défoncés [rires]
au doping pour gagner une médaille et
cetera et tout. C'est c'est ça a plus de
sens. Voilà,
il y a des contrôles antidopage.
Ouais. Bon enfin bon quand on voit la
moyenne du Tour de France, ils vont plus
vite que l'époque où les mecs étaient
dopés. Donc ils ont peut-être trouvé un
truc. Ça dit je trouve que le courage
des gamins il est admirable. Même
défoncer ce qu'ils font c'est c'est très
courageux. Maintenant non mais c'est ça
le paradoxe. C'est que le gars sa vie
c'est de pédaler. Pas
quelqu'un qui a proposé de faire un un
événement sportif où il y aurait que des
dopés. Bahçon c'est plus ou moins le
cas. Ouais mais non voilà voilà c'est
c'est
le fait qu'on qu'on demande au au
logement étudiant d'être libre au moment
des
Non c'est complètement con. C'est
complètement con. Voilà. Enfin c'est ça
politique hors sol quoi. C'est bien un
truc que ce pays devrait devenir ça
serait une énorme une énorme université
un énorme hôpital intelligent pour
soigner les gens. Ça devrait être ça ce
pays aujourd'hui. Une Suisse mentale
bienveillante sécurisante dans lequel on
venir tous les cerveaux du monde et les
encourager les subventionner.
Aujourd'hui, ils partent aux États-Unis
à cause de l'argent. Voyez les cerveaux
français, les mecs brillants, ils se
barrent, ils se barrent aux États-Unis
parce que là-bas il y a des fondations
et un système qui est un pays quand même
très très égoïste mais ils ont quand
même un système pour encourager les
forces vives quoi. Et ce pays, ça
devrait être que ça ce pays.
L'université partout. Il y a pas
longtemps, je passe à Poissie, j'habite
dans la région et je vois naïvement des
bâtiments qui se construisent partout et
cetera et je vois marquer un truc avec
Paris. Je dis bah ça c'est bien, il faut
une université en région parisienne et
en fait non, c'est prochain centre
d'entraînement du PSG. [rires]
entre entre rire et chagrin, je sais pas
quoi, je crois c'estement con mais des
bâtiments, vous auriez vu les mecs tout
ça pour que les mecs joue à la babal
quand même. Alors c'est c'estar qui doit
financer mais on en est dans ce ridicule
là quoi.
Du pain et des jeux
hein.
Du pain et des jeux.
Bah oui complètement. Ouais. Ouais. Il y
a une phrase de Toxville qui a été
écrite en 1840 dans de la démocratie en
Amérique et il dit parce qu'à l'époque
on est encore sous les rois en France et
qu'il va en Amérique, il étudie le le
phénomène de la démocratie. Il est
écrit, "C'est évident que la démocratie
sera le mode de gouvernement futur dans
lequel les gouvernants s'occuperont du
bien-être des gens pour peu que les gens
ne s'occupent que de leur bien-être."
Allez, non, ça a été écrit à 150 ans, on
est en plein dedans là. Et comme on
étouffe un peu la parole, enfin on
étouffe même beaucoup la parole
citoyenne, bah voilà
le green,
l'uniforme à l'école,
je trouve quatement con ça. Ouais, moi
je l'ai eu moi j'étais en l'internat, ça
rigolait pas cravate et tout. Squatement
con. Non, squatement con. Non, qu'on
qu'on mette pas un autre type d'uniforme
qui l'uniforme religieux. Oui, mais
qu'on met pas non plus l'uniforme
classique squatement con. Mais l'école,
c'est pareil. Euh si vous voulez euh il
y a des gros débats. Moi, je trouve que
le un instituteur quand il fait l'école,
il apprend à l'école normale. L'école
normale. Alors, il y a deux écoles
normales. L'école normale supérieure qui
est très connue, on recrute les élites
puis a l'école normale. Mais c'est quoi
le normal ? C'est la norme républicaine.
Donc c'est pour formater des gamins dans
dans dans l'esprit républicain. Alors
c'est on parle beaucoup de Jules Ferry
d'ici Jules Ferry Boulev Chafer Ferry
école Julferie. Jules Ferry a imposé
cette nomme en 1882 et on dit formidable
d'imposer l'école obligatoire. Mais il
faut savoir queune des raisons de cette
école obligatoire c'est qu'en 70 les
Français avaient perdu contre les
Prussiens. Ils sont rendus compte que
les Français étaient moins éduqués.
Beaucoup de français ne parlaient pas
français entre eux. Il y avait les
Bretons, il y avait les Gascons, les
machins. Donc il fallait vraiment que
tout le monde parle de français.
Beaucoup de Breton dans mes ancêtres ont
été obligés d'apprendre le français.
C'est même pas le droit de parler
Breton. à l'école et et et donc Jul
Ferry il a fait ça aussi et ça a marché
puisque on a gagné la guerre de 14 avec
1400000 morts donc ils étaient formatés
pour la bagarre donc voilà la pédagogie
collective j'y crois pas la pédagogie
personnalisée avec les écoles
alternatives j'y crois et je trouve
c'est intéressant qu'on devrait former
les instituteurs.
Montessouris c'est ça ? Ouais, il y a
tout et n'importe quoi chez Montessie
mais il il y a Frainet jour quand on a
un film l'école buon de Jean-Paul le
Channois 1848 avec Bliz euh pas Bertrand
Bernard et qui raconte très bien
l'arrivée de Frainet post première
guerre mondiale dans un petit village en
province et qui commence avec des
précepts nouveaux à inventer de
nouvelles pédagogies. Il y a Fren il y a
eu un un grand un grand pédagogue en
Espagne Ferrer, qui était tellement
efficace que les jésuites ont fini par
le fusiller. Enfin, c'est pour vous
dire. Non, mais bien sûr que l'éducation
est au centre du problème. Vous avez c
cette école
que j'évoque dans dans mes rêves ou que
je vois que je rencontre. Il a il y a
une école dans le centre de Paris qui
s'appelle Ellipse qui est une petite
école. Ils sont 20 par classe. Il y a
deux profs, ils ont en cours de voilà
c'est ça coûte des sous, c'est des
écoles privées. Mais si ce schéma là
pédagogique était enseigné aux
instituteurs et en donnant le choix.
vous le classique ou le l'alternatif, je
pense que vous auriez des gamins dans 20
ans, c'est rapide dans 20 ans qui
auraient une autre façon de raisonner
qui serait beaucoup moins dans la
compétition, beaucoup plus dans
l'écologie, beaucoup plus dans
l'altruisme. Je connais une autre école
dans l'indrome où la l'institutrice a 10
% ou 20 % de ses effectifs, ça doivent
être un impérativement des handicapés.
La meilleure façon d'apprendre au gamin
que un handicapé c'est pas quelqu'un de
d'inférieur, c'est juste quelqu'un de
différent, bah c'est tout très tôt quoi.
C'est une école dans la drô s'appelle
les Amanins. Voilà, j'espère les
Amanins, je sais pas cette école
Finger Cross et dans Paris c'est une
petite école mais c'est privée, ça
s'appelle l'ellipse. Voilà, c'est c'est
très chouette aussi. Voilà.
Question internet. Question pour
monsieur Dupontel. Envisagez-vous un
jour de faire une série TV sur une
plateforme comme Netflix, Amazon ou
Apple ? Ce format intéresserait-il ?
avec beaucoup de cynisme, si je peux
plus faire de cinéma, oui, je ferai des
séries. Netflix nous a déjà sollicité à
l'époque du du confinement d'ailleurs.
Et l'idée que j'avais, c'était de faire
les trois mousquetaires mais alors à la
vraie version de de Duma parce qu'on
vous lisait vraiment le bouquin, il est
assez trash, les histoires sont assez
trashes. Bref, voyez donc moi pour
l'instant quand je peux faire du
sinoche, j'en fais. Je trouve ça
vraiment chouette le côté la réunion à
plusieurs, la grande salle, le grand
écran, le son, je trouve ça super. Je
bibonne aussi à des séries
euh euh télévisées tard le soir quand
quand qu'on échange des [rires] des SMS.
Mais euh mais c'est voilà, je ferme pas
du tout la porte hein. Si je peux si
vraiment à m'emmener je peux plus. Puis
il y a des choses chouettes qui ont été
faites. J'ai beaucoup aimé le le roman
de Quaron que qui a été fait par
Netflix. Netflix donne beaucoup de sous
des fois des signas à des grands signas
pour pour faire des grands films. Alors
c'est dommage que que ça ne reste que
sur un petit écran mais au moins ces
grands signates peuvent s'exprimer donc
ça c'est chouette.
Vous avez testé le casque à réalité
virtuelle ou pas ? Oui, c'est assez
terrifiant. Ouais, ouais, c'est assez
terrifiant. Il y en a un, je l'ai pas
fait, mais l'affichiste de mon
affichiste légendaire qui les plus grand
affichistes en France, c'est Laurent
Lufroid, a testé un casque virtuel il y
a quelques années. Il m'a raconté que ça
de ils sont dans une pièce, ils mettent
le casque virtuel et puis ils vont se
promener et à la fin, il y a un type qui
vous braque avec un flingue et 9 et demi
personnes sur 10 se mettent à genou
tellement il sont Non, il y en a pas un.
Il y en a qui il s'est pas il s'est pas
mis à genou mais qu'il pouvait pas.
[rires] Il était âgé, il pouvait pas.
Mais c'est c'est fou quand même. Et et
j'étais on a été reçu au GGN. C'est
toujours des gens j'admire ces mecs-là.
Donc ils nous ont invité et j'ai un tout
petit gamin qui est très rigolo qui a 9
ans et cetera et tout. Puis alors il
voit on voit il y a une barrière au sol
comme ça. Il y a il y a une petite
poutre sur le sol et on leur met un
casque virtuel et on leur dit vous vous
allez marcher dessus le casque virtuel.
Et mon gamin très prétentieusement a dit
je vais être plus fort que mon cerveau.
Donc il est monté sur le truc mais au
bout avec le cass virtuel il y a le
vide. Personne personne ne va sur le
parquet.
Ça c'est terrible ça. Vous parlez de
chat GPT machin et tout. Oui, on peut
courtcircuiter notre conscience. On a
beau savoir que c'est virtuel n'empêche
qu'on saute pas et où on se met à parce
qu'un flingue vous est présenté sous le
pif. C'est c'est terrifiant. Et on
rentre dans un monde où la réalité est
tellement enl dit justement par des
politiques qui sont hors sol ou par une
parole qui est qui est pas bonne que le
gros refuge des gamins, c'est c'est le
virtuel. Et moi aussi d'ailleurs moi à
l'orage je me remis dans les syoges
parce que je préférais le virtuel à la
réalité. Donc aujourd'hui virtuel ou
l'archaïme ?
Bah c'est pas l'archaïsme c'est c'est
c'est il y a des gens qui drappent notre
réalité d'une leader. La consommation
est une leader. La publicité est une
leader. Le discours politique est une à
tel qu'il est pratiqué est une leader.
Il finit par voir que ça le bou il se
réfugie dans dans le virtuel comme moi
je me réfugie dans dans les bouquins,
dans les films. Je passe je vois deux
films par jour. Ouais, je je je rêve
dans les films, je m'évane dans les
films, je vis dans les films, j'existe
dans le quotidien. Vraie nuance. Voilà,
Newton me menote.
Question internet. Comment a-t-il vécu
l'épisode Covid ?
Euh, comme gens planqué chez soi, puis
comme j'ai la chance d'avoir plus de
sous que la moyenne, on éit planqué à la
campagne avec mes petits gars et voilà.
et j'écrivais, j'ai commencé à écrire
second tour. Voilà, j'ai regardé vos
émissions. Il y a pas eu beaucoup
d'émissions pendant le Covid, vous avez
quasiment fait aucune. La communauté
nous a dit vous prenez pas de risque,
vous restez chez vous. On a encore
quelques traces des des masques.
La communauté vous a dit, vous êtes des
gros lâches. Bah la communauté a raison.
De quoi ? [rires]
Non mais non voilà, j'ai bibronné à
plein de trucs. Euh j'ai beaucoup lu,
j'ai beaucoup vu de film, c'était même
euh
et [grognement] en tant que élève
apprenti tout bib euh euh feu ou du
moins passer euh voir la la ministre
S'agiter, voir des affichettes Sagit.
Ah je trouve ça désolant parce que le
spectacle qu'ils ont donné est terrible.
La la fille qui a démissionné en plein
en plein Covid,
elle se présentait aux élections à Paris
quand même
pour remplacer un gars qui s'est tripoté
de zizi sur internet. Voilà hors sol.
D'ailleurs, il en a fait un petit peu
mention, je connaissais pas l'épisode he
c'est mon équipe qu' on cherchait au
montage, on cherchait un truc pour
expliquer pourquoi notre candidat
s'était lancé à la campagne. On m'a dit
"Tu connais pas cette histoire ? On a
inventé Zizigate." Voilà. Et c'est David
Marseille de Palmachud.
De quoi ?
David Marseille, grand acteur du
Palmachot qui est venu, je lui dis
"Est-ce que tu peux venir pour un petit
gag Sagas et Fugace ?" Il est venu faire
ça [rires]
dans la salle de montage. Voilà, parce
qu'on a on a réintroduit ça post post
tournage. Mais ça, je trouve ça je
trouve ça terrible. Je trouve ça
terrible vraiment. D'abord, il y a des
missions, il y a des missions de poste
en temps de crise quand même. Et elle a
dit qu'elle était au courant. Bah si
elle était au courant, fallait dire
"Écoutez-moi, je me barre, je
démissionne, je quitte la vie
politique." Enfin quand même. Merde, il
y a des il y a des
Macron répondait pas au téléphone.
J'en sais rien. Mais c'est c'est Non
mais je vous dis, ils sont ils sont dans
un dans un dans un autre raisonnement et
puis ils sont dans un microcosme où ils
se persuent les uns les autres. Ils sont
dans un comparatif mutuel, ils sortent
pas du tout de leur bulle. Mais les
financiers, c'est pareil. Pourquoi des
mecs de 70 piges continuent à vouloir
s'enrichir ? Ils sont déjà bourrés de
tune parce qu'ils veulent leur
jubilation, c'est c'est d'arriver à
faire des affaires plus que leurs
voisins et cetera et cetera. Donc voilà,
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes, toutes
mes excuses.
Est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Ah, des bouquins euh
je n'ai plus que trois. Comme ça, pour
avoir l'air sérieux dans votre
communauté, je recommanderai l'histoire
populaire euh des États-Unis, des USA,
de Ardine qui est un bouquin
extraordinaire dont les lectures ont été
faites par des grands acteurs
hollywoodiens, Mat Démon en tête et
cetera. C'est un un il est qualifié
comme activiste aujourd'hui euh par le
la la l l'établishment américain où il a
été il a il a participé été au Patagon
Paper, c'est lui qui tenait la
photocopieuse qui a planqué les gens et
cetera et tout. Donc une vraie histoire,
il a une vraie présence dans l'histoire
américaine. Il était bombardier pendant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale euh dans un
avion. Il il était en train de déverser
du napal mme sur Royan où 25 ans après,
j'ai fait des pâtés et c'est en
déversant ce produit qu'ils
expérimentaient, c'était de Napalm donc
cette bonne ville de Royant où mes
grands-parents avaient planqué ma mère.
pendant la guerre, c'était pas une
c'était pas une super idée. Et il a pris
conscience de ce qu'il était en train de
faire. Et après, il a eu le droit au Job
Act, c'est qu'il avait le droit de
d'avoir une bourse pour faire des
études. Il est devenu historien,
respecté, respectable. Et quand vous
lisez l'histoire des États-Unis ou la
l'histoire populaire aux États-Unis,
vous comprenez tout ce qui s'est passé
au 20e siècle, la la mentalité
américaine et les déviances qu'on a eu à
subir en Europe et c donc voilà, je
recommande ce bouquin qui est absolument
passionnant. Euh trois autres livres,
qu'est-ce que je pourrais vous dire pour
alors un un truc terrifiant du grand
Pierre Lem qui s'appelle robe de marié.
C'est un petit polar mais terrifiant
qui se lit rapidement qui voilà qui que
j'ai relu il y a pas longtemps qui est
effroyable. Et puis un troisème bouquin.
Alors je sais pas
euh euh je sais pas vous me prenez
pourant je savais que vous posez cette
question mais j'ai j'ai pas réfléchi.
Euh bah je sais pas
[__] je vais regretter après de pas
avoir dit euh
réfléchissons.
Qu'est-ce que j'ai lu récemment qui m'a
qui m'a plu ?
Ben je sais pas peut-être les les
mémoires de guerre de Gaulle. Voilà,
c'est intéressant. Voilà, c'est ça.
Ouais.
trois films. Alors, il a plus que trois,
je pourrais donner. Alors, je je veux
donner trois catégories. Voilà, je vais
prendre des grands films poétiques qui
pour moi la poésie si vous voulez c'est
la façon la plus noble de s'exprimer.
C'est c'est c'est des questions qui
n'ont pas besoin de réponse. Voilà, ça
c'est la poésie. Voyez ? Alors, il y a
des cinéas qui sont risqués à ça. Alors,
en France, on a un grand cinéas, c'est
bllié. Je pense à Buff et froid et
pratiquement toute son œuvre trop belle
pour toi et le début, je pense de Merci
La vie qui est prodigieux. Il y a
également, je vous recommande le le
grand classique du cinéma poétique,
c'est 8 et demi pour moi de Fellini,
Muland Drive de Lynch et puis également
plus récent, j'ai beaucoup aimé la
grande desbedza, même si la génération
d'audessus dit que c'est un copiercollé
de la Dolchiv Vita. Bon, moi je trouve
c'est une version vraiment très très
chouette. Voilà, c'est c'est un cinéma
très poétique. Alors après, je vais
prendre dans les classiques dans les
classiques, pour moi les classiques du
cinéma français c'est les années 30,
c'est renoir du Vivier Carnet. Alors, je
vous recommanderai la chienne de renoir.
Je vous recommanderai euh
[grognement] euh je vous recommanderai
la chienne de renoir. Je vous
recommanderai panique de du vivier.
Peut-être que je l'ai déjà dit, mais je
le redis, c'est pas grave. Je vous
recommanderai euh les enfants du
paradis, euh le grand classique du
cinéma français avec Carnet que j'ai eu
la chance de croiser quand il était
vivant. Maintenant qu'il est mort,
évidemment, je le croise un peu moins.
Et puis dans le cinéma contemporain
récent,
Friedkin est mort il y a pas longtemps.
Je vous recommanderai French Connection
de Chimino, je vous recommanderai voyage
au bout de l'enfer, lui aussi est parti.
Et puis sur vos écrans Penimer, voilà
vraiment que je trouve vraiment
formidable. Voilà,
un conseil pour les jeunes générations,
une bouteille à la mer.
Bah, je déjà dit mais
[raclement de gorge]
bonne chance déjà à vous puisque
l'avenir s'annonce vraiment compliqué.
[grognement]
Contester l'autorité Christ sans tout
péter hein. C'est pas la peine d'aller
brûler les gamins qui ont été brûlés des
cinémas parce qu'on avait tué ce pauvre
gosse je je trouve ça quatement naïf et
stupide. Ne brûlez pas des cinémas c'est
c'est c'est c'est vous
des médiathèques ni des écoles.
C'est c'est vous vous suicidez vous-même
squatement con. Donc faut vraiment que
quelqu'un parle à ses gamins pour qu'ils
arrêtent d'agir comme ça. Euh
une chose d'ailleurs.
J'avais une pensée brillante mais qui
m'a quêement échappé. Euh repose la
question, ça va revenir. Un conseil pour
les jeunes. Oui, voilà ce il y a un
philosophe indien qui s'appelle Christ
Murti qui dit que contester l'autorité
c'est le début de la créativité. Voilà.
Alors contester contester l'autorité de
façon intérieure. Il s'agit pas de
[__] le feu à l'école. Justement euh
mettez en doute ce que vous dit le
professeur. Mettez en doute ce que dit
vos parents. Mettez en doute ce que vous
dit le monde environnant. Voilà. La
vérité elle est en vous. Accédez à
vous-même. Ça c'est dur. Ça c'est c'est
très très dur ça parce que effectivement
à peine encore une fois que j'aie
expliqué on est pris en otage très vite
par l'environnement. Voilà.
Voilà. Alors voilà, contestez
intelligemment l'autorité et donc soyez
créatifs.
Albert Dupi.
Salut. Merci bien. Merci à vous. Voilà.
Bon.
[musique]